jury selection
in the derek shavin trial it's actually
kind of looking good
for chavin at least for the time being
this is the george floyd case
and this guy's being charged with
second-degree second-degree murder and
manslaughter
and we've got a couple things one
apparently one of the jurors who was
selected said black lives matter is too
extreme and hasn't seen the george floyd
video
another juror was a woman of color who
apparently has a relative who is a cop
so that
interestingly it probably is favorable
for chauvin
in in some ways especially saying black
lives matter's a bit too extreme but
i think both sides so you know they
they've expressed themselves in these
jurors so they're probably satisfied
with them to a certain degree
but we have another crazy story within
this jackpot tweeted one of the jurors
said they feared
that if their name was released their
home would be attacked by leftist
rioters
and they're right absolutely correct i
mean
no matter what happens they're not
satisfied with even the charges
laid out on chauvin now they want first
degree murder in fact i'm sure some of
them would be calling for the death
penalty
so even if you get second degree murder
which is extremely unlikely they're not
going to be satisfied
if he ends up with manslaughter they're
not going to be satisfied and so we have
another story locals in minneapolis are
starting to freak out because they're
genuinely concerned about what's going
to happen so we'll talk about this a
bunch of other stories but ladies and
gentlemen
it's my birthday it is in fact my
birthday and we are hanging out with
cassandra fairbanks because in a couple
days it's her it's her birthday
double birthday show yeah and uh
thank you and uh actually we had a super
chat coming right away from uh
henry who says it's his wife rachel's
birthday so shout out to rachel happy
birthday
you have a really good birthday by the
way so we're gonna chill we're hanging
out i'm not stressing it's my birthday
you know we're gonna have a fun time and
talk about whatever and uh cassandra
how's it going good
no complaints you want to just introduce
yourself and um
i write for gateway pundit i have known
tim forever
i've been on here a few times now i
don't really know how to describe
myself you uh you write yes you cause
trouble on twitter yes there you go
i am a troublemaker on twitter and i
quite enjoy it
for now i'm gonna probably be banned
soon
well it's only a matter of time i keep
telling people to delete their histories
like the
like every software's gonna delete
everything yeah cause that that one
woman
that corrupt journalists from axios who
was dating the guy
in the bite administration and then like
don't worry it's not a violation of
ethics when it like
was she got rewarded with an
editor-in-chief physician at
uh uh teen vogue which is a creepy
publication as it is
but uh now they're coming after her for
10 year old tweets
she was like 17 and she tweeted some
dumb things and they're like
she should not be allowed to work here
because she failed the purity test ten
years ago
yeah well that's how it goes i guess or
at least private can you private tweets
private stuff i have mine set to delete
every week now yeah you can set your
account to find it
yeah just delete it all just they have
like a bunch of absolutely
what's going on ian hey man it's not
your birthday no it's not my birthday
not until next month
april 2nd there will be a season hey 34
was really good for you man
it was really fun great to be able to
watch we'll see what 35 does i'm excited
yeah so it's very impressive for a 34
year old man to be doing what you're
doing so this is really cool i'm 35 now
that's true
i don't know man you know it is whatever
it is it's impressive it is
being a weird place who knows i'll
humiliate you later oh all right
i don't know you know it's like you know
you get to 35 and everyone's like at
your birthday what are you doing i'm
like i'm not working
it's cool man start a start an empire in
your 30s that's like that's
the american dream some people's
american dream
high school dropout yeah that's pretty
impressive yeah i was thinking about it
earlier you know i hear a lot from
a lot of lefties they so some guy was
accusing me
they love projecting they really just
don't watch this show they were like
are you gonna go around blaming poor
people for being poor again and i was
like when did i ever do that
like do you know who i am i don't come
on the show i'm like damn poor people
they're so lazy i don't say that i'm
like usually pretty much like social
programs are good
we just need to like we have the
corruption and fix them and i like talk
about how social programs helped me
through
homelessness but these people really
want to project they want to assume that
simply because i'm like democrats are
crooked
i must be rush limbaugh or something you
know like certain certainly not
it's so easy to yell random stuff that's
all they do
and i'm thinking about it and i'm like i
really do think
that you know it's a combination of hard
work perseverance
and opportunity you can call it luck
that really helps you get to a certain
position but there was a study
there's a ted talk about a series of
studies and you know the
one trait was they identified in all
stories of success
it wasn't height it wasn't weight it
wasn't gender it wasn't race it wasn't
class it wasn't whether you were born in
it with a silver spoon in the suburbs or
born in this in
in the inner city one thing perseverance
the people who refused to give up and
kept working ended up being successful
and accomplishing their goals
and when they were asked about it you
know they found that was the one
attribute
some people who are not that smart but
never stopped working ended up building
something
i guess a lot of people uh need to
understand that certainly don't think
it's anyone's fault if they don't
and i'm even in favor of school loan
student loan forgiveness in a certain
capacity not the way they're doing it
we're like write everybody a check
i'm not in favor of that i'd like to
forgive the interest that's what i'm
saying i'm saying cut the interest off
right now
you owe what you spent but you know
someone
who borrows 40 grand owing 200 grand
later makes no sense that's rough
yeah yeah it's totally brutal yeah i i
borrowed 20 grand
and i have paid about 15 of it off and i
owe 21 grand
right that's insane it's insane right
you you've paid back what you
were given you know or it's like you
should pay back what you were given but
at a certain point it becomes predatory
so i think the first one got to do is
stop colleges from doing it but anyway
anyway i digress
we're gonna talk about what's going on
with this stuff don't forget we got
lydia president i am pushing all the
buttons in the corner this is the second
birthday i've got to hang out with tim
which is always fun
george alexapolis made a little cartoon
for tim on this illustrious beanie
appreciation day so you guys check it
out over on my twitter it's amazing
it's great it's me feeding chickens
feeding chickens
and then i get abducted by aliens and
the chickens are looking up like shocked
we are building a chicken city yeah
oh we're going to highlight that it's
beautiful we'll film it we'll fill up
we should put a camera on the chicken
city and just live stream it mm-hmm
which chicken is your favorite i think
we're getting four is that
you said four maybe i don't know we got
to see like we have a decent amount of
space so
yeah i want to get 12. i don't know
but we're also going to be doing
gardening with chickens oh yeah chicken
city so
my friends it's my birthday see what
that means go to timcast.com
and become a member to get exclusive
access
or access to exclusive content yesterday
was really funny we were hanging out
with clifton duncan
and we were talking about super straight
versus like you know trans issues
and then somehow it turned into a
discussion on god and energy you're
talking about the universe
well it's like it turned into it yeah it
turned into like you know a dmt
and so uh i have a feeling that's gonna
happen a lot yeah okay
i think it's because everyone's so
fascinated by it it is interesting it's
everywhere it's in all of us
so you can do one of two things or both
you can super chat for my birthday which
i see a lot of people are already doing
thank you very much
or just become a member become a member
and stay a member and we are going to
grow and expand
and it's funny because right now we're
watching all of these you know news
outlets
they're just laying people off like
crazy huffy didn't post got hit with
layoffs you're going to have to learn
how to build solar panels really quickly
all right build solar panels learn to
build solar panels
i like i like the memes or they're like
perhaps they could take a course
perhaps they could take a course on the
uh what do they say um
the practical application of software
development yes
yes so many learn to code are we allowed
to say that now i don't know
the practical application of software
development yeah uh yeah become a member
and we got a bunch of stuff up so uh
let's do that
let's just uh i think this will be a bit
more chill of a day
because i actually had a lot of people
saying like don't work tim just go
and you know make s'mores by the fire
and i'm like hey look
it's my birthday we don't you know we
will hang out we'll talk about stuff so
uh check this out
those aren't familiar the george floyd
trial
it's the trial of derek chaven is is
happening now
there's already been thousands of people
protesting and there are fears that
riots are going to break out they're
putting up barricades they're bringing
in 2000 national guard
earlier today jury selection was
happening and
it is particularly boring to watch and
it's really
not like the movies a lot of people
don't don't get this they think it's
going to be like the prosecutor saying
mr juror you tweeted that you were
racist
aha we've caught you it's just very much
like thank you for joining us um do you
think there's anything that might get in
the way of your judgment
no i don't i think i'll do a good job
okay how do you feel about you know the
media's coverage oh i wasn't familiar
it's like okay it's like very very dry
and boring
something interesting happened jack
bosobic tweets breaking
juror number eight says he is concerned
rioters will attack his house
if he serves on the jury and his name is
released in the george floyd trial
zobek goes on to say he uh adds he would
be concerned about them coming after his
wife and kids
he's not wrong i i watched a good amount
of the stream today
not i don't think i saw that part but um
there were quite a few people who um
who mentioned that really or like who
mentioned being afraid
wow yeah so right now
you know whenever i talk to lefties
about what's going on with
the riots and black lives matter they
act like it doesn't happen they're like
oh but it was mostly peaceful and it's
like they really do
gobble up the mainstream narrative and
i'm like what does it mean mostly
peaceful
yeah like not peaceful because it was
mostly like so mostly peaceful means
like
as a whole it was violent mostly
yeah the lawyer was asking people he was
like you know how do you feel about the
fact that they had to put up all this
stuff outside the courthouse to protect
it
wow like does that freak you out does it
make you feel more safe wait they were
asking the jurors that
yeah wow and the guys were like well
more safe i guess oh yeah i saw that i
saw that how do you feel about the fact
that yeah
wow man so so it sounds like it's pretty
good for
derek chavin yeah you confirm that's how
you pronounce it as chauvin
i don't know i was saying chauvin like
chauvinism oh yeah i don't know
i don't know where they are
we don't know whatever uh but check us
out so we have the story from fox news
scary to watch minneapolis business
owners on edge
over possible repeat of riots bar owner
dermot crowley recalls feeling like
nobody was in charge last spring
and he's right man it's not just him
it's a bunch of other people
you've got the police department was
decimated they they defunded the police
they all voted for it
then crime and homicide skyrocketed and
then they were like
uh what do we do and then the
constituents started complaining and
then
the the city council was like bring back
the police and now they got to spend
what is it like six million dollars
i think 6.4 6.4 million dollars to bring
cops back right
yep dude is it going to be like fresh
cops
like rookies or are they bringing i
think i think so well i think it'll
probably be a lot of rookies but it'll
probably be like from other departments
they got to offer a lot of money wow
i think you got to be really dumb to
take that job though jeez
could you imagine like there's a guy on
on trial for second degree murder
and you we can we can criticize you know
i think manslaughter is the argument not
murder at all
but we've already seen the photo they
were trained to do exactly what he did
yeah i don't think that he should even
be found guilty of manslaughter
and i had people to i tweeted this the
other day and of course people were
really upset about it but then
somebody was like well they have to find
him at least guilty of something because
otherwise the city is going to burn
and i was like what the hell kind of
logic is that that's horrible
they're collectivists it is better that
the collective survives
and the individual suffer that's like
that's that's like bismarck
when it was otto von bismarck is that
his name yeah he said it was better that
ten innocent people suffer than one
guilty person escape
it wasn't it the opposite of that though
well the blackstone's formulation is
it is better that 10 guilty persons
escape than one innocent person suffer
right
this guy was the authoritarian who was
like it is better that 10 innocent
people suffer
than one guilty person escaped nah
it's like straight up mob rule like this
guy tweeted at me like so earnestly
about it and i was just like
dumbfounded like it takes a lot to shock
me on twitter now like i lurk the pretty
bad weird parts of the internet
but i was like wow people like actually
believe this they actually believe that
whether he's guilty or not is irrelevant
because the city will burn yeah that's
horrible you think he's
not just your opinion is he's not like
what he did because
i don't think he should be found guilty
of anything at all the the knee on the
neck for what nine minutes they were
trying to do the nano the next right
the only real argument is did he do it
too long yeah and the problem with that
is
manslaughter is like basically you are
negligent and you cause someone's death
there's an argument okay that he was
kneeling too long and when george floyd
became unresponsive
they should have been monitoring the
situation better but also i think we
i it's it's it's hard to know man people
seem they see these things
and they're like i know exactly what i
would do that situation you give
somebody
we talked about this we talked about the
other day you give someone a handgun
who's never shot a handgun before and
they're surprised they can't hit
anything with it
and then try and put them in one of
these situations and they think they
know what would happen
for all we know shavin was just like his
mind was going a mile a minute and he's
got people around him screaming and
filming
and so he's just totally pulled from the
moment
and he's he's kneeling on on george
floyd because the tra they were trained
to do it
and he did it for several minutes too
long without but the thing is though
like i watched that video and i feel
like i watched a completely different
video than the left
because george floyd was out of control
like
what were they supposed to do they had
him in the cop car and then he was like
no i gotta get out i gotta lay down i
got like
he said lay me on the ground three times
and so they keep saying that they were
worried about like
excited delirium because he was clearly
on drugs we're in the middle of pandemic
he wasn't wearing a mask he had the
coronavirus didn't he
yes and so what are they supposed to do
they have to keep that guy's head away
from them
it's a pandemic that's crazy too we're
seeing it everywhere
i saw a toxicology report that said that
he was intoxicated on fentanyl
yeah and other things everything yeah
caffeine he had in his system no there
was like
fentanyl and and like methamphetamines
yeah and caffeine was one too they found
so tucker was bold the tucker said
he did die of overdose but the the
medical examiner said that's not what he
reported
that i guess the general idea from the
medical examiner is
it was a combination of all of these
factors which i guess the suggestion is
if he wasn't restrained that way
he would not have died oh i see so yeah
i saw
two medical examiner reports one was
from the family and they said
asphyxiation death and then another one
came out
and said it was a heart failure and that
could have been brought on by the
trauma from the neck they said it was an
underlying heart condition with drugs in
the system
and you know combined with the restraint
so i guess the the issue is do you trust
the family when they come out and they
say oh yeah it's exactly what they're
not using
that report i don't trust anyone at face
value i want more
i want to look at all the evidence i
think he's gonna
uh well i don't know what's gonna happen
i think there's a there's a strong
possibility like we're looking
let me let me pull this jared thing real
quick so i can give some context the
daily mail says
revealed white chemist who thinks black
lives matter is too extreme
and hasn't seen the george floyd video
and woman of color who's related to a
cop are the first two jurors selected in
derek chavin's trial
so that so far i'm like that sounds
favorable for chevin i mean a guy who
thinks black lives matter is too extreme
he's probably approaching this from a
more neutral but
i mean it sounds like he's biased
against black lives matter not that i
think black lives matter
will play a big role in whether or not
chavin did right or wrong because it's
not like george floyd was literally a
black lives matter activist
but then you have this woman who's
related to a cop so to what degree
is she related to him is it like her
uncle she doesn't talk to or is it you
know her brother who tells her stories
every single day
right you know that i think that'll be
interesting
related to a police officer but i think
either way so far this leans in his
favor
especially when you consider all of
these jurors like you were mentioning
have to walk into this building
surrounded by barricades and razor wire
and cops
and then they're like how do you feel
knowing they had to do this
that's crazy and who was it was it was
the defense attorney asking that
that's a great question yeah but i like
his question i thought he was great i
actually really like the lawyer
i think he's clever the defense guy yeah
i wonder how much the prosecutors really
want to
to sink chavin as well because that's
the thing that's why i say i don't know
what's gonna happen because there's
politics involved
and politics can make this go any
direction yeah it could be
we can't let the city burn so just throw
them throw them in the gulag and throw
away the key
maybe or maybe they're like we're
suffering
the homicide rate is through the roof
the riots are going to happen no matter
what we do
yeah and if we lock this cop up we're
not going to be able to get any more
cops in this city
yeah considering their spending was at
6.4 million i wouldn't be surprised if
they're like
you know throw it throw it to the to to
the prosecutor just like
you know throw the throw the case let
him win let him get off and then we can
say we did what we're supposed to do
they're going to ride no matter what we
do and then we can tell all the cops
don't worry you won't go to prison
i'm kind of nervous about the juror that
said he was afraid they were going to
attack his
family if so that means like if he's
afraid of of being
if he's being that sounds like he's
being coerced already like why would you
put a juror on the jury then well why
wouldn't you be afraid that they're
going to attack your family
i mean people will come to your house
and launch fireworks at it for mean
tweets
i mean that was you yeah yeah i have a
really
uh strong opinion about this because
personal experience
but i mean why wouldn't you think that
like minneapolis activists were going to
people's houses they had a doxing
facebook group where they posted
addresses and
different things and people who were
trump supporters like they had a mob go
to somebody's house just because they
had a trump flag last year
i i was we were talking it was last year
was the day that happened to you
and i was talking about how like with
all the riots going on you know at the
house we got to be we got to be careful
and everybody should be
vigilant and you know keep your eyes and
ears open and ready because
we might start seeing people show up at
houses and i remember some of my friends
were just like i don't think so man
no look like they're protesting and
riding without going to people's houses
and then like the next like the next day
i see cassandra being like they were at
my house banging on the doors firing
fireworks
and i'm just like let's get that house
look at that yeah
yeah let's go move to the woods i was
covering the riot that night and it was
like two miles to my house you know
where i lived it was
you know pretty close to the white house
and it was the night they burnt that
church
and i was talking to my boyfriend on the
phone and i was like i'm kind of freaked
out i got like
way more specific death threats than
normal today
because i get them all the time but like
people are messaging me like my address
and dming me my address and all this
stuff and i was like i'm a little
worried but i guess i'm gonna go to bed
and then like literally two minutes
after i got off the phone i was here
like
i was like wow and it was fireworks they
were shooting your window
yeah so i heard this car come up and
they like screeched around the corner
and it was right after the riot ended so
i was covering the riot and i was like
okay it looks like it's all done
everybody's
you know settling down it was like four
o'clock in the morning
and then like just minutes later i hear
this car like screech and then slam the
brakes because they lived on a corner
and they like turned that way and then
they get out and like fireworks just
start
launching at my house and then i hear
somebody banging on my window with what
sounded like stick
or something and then you had some media
activists
go around claiming that you made up made
the whole story up yeah
so he said that he talked to my
neighbors who had a black lives matter
flag
in their window but my boyfriend went
over there and was like hey did you
talk to him they were like no nobody
even came here
yeah um fake news and and they came to
like my halloween party and stuff like
i'm friendly with them
yeah and so they were like we'll go on
record saying he's lying if you want
but yeah he claimed that like there was
just happened to be fireworks at my
house
were you at 4am was it first floor yeah
and were there bars on the windows
no so i yeah it was not fun
and my daughter was home with that man
so earlier theirs is like there's like
this controversy going on right now with
twitter
new york times rep as a new york times
reporter who
is you know tweeting about how she's
getting harassed i don't know if you saw
these two i just tweeted about that yeah
so uh i'll just say that i don't wanna i
don't wanna
you know contribute to the fire so i
think i'll just leave the name leave her
name out of it yeah but she's she's
a prominent you know um i guess i don't
want to say culture war
because she doesn't entirely cover
cultural war subjects but she does you
know dip her feet into the culture war
issues and cause
trouble she had tweeted that this vc guy
marc andreessen said the
r word on clubhouse and it wasn't true
and so she tweeted today it's like you
know international i think was it what
was it about international media
she's like my life my life has been
destroyed
by online harassment or something and
then she linked to some site that's
advocating for
like online like ending online violence
so they view mean tweets and
harassment as violence and so you end up
with like
glenn greenwald and michael tracy and
just a bunch of
i'm not gonna they're not conservatives
they're just like the politically
homeless sect of you know former liberal
journalists saying like your life was
not destroyed
this is so over the top and this is
somebody with all the institutional
power of the new york times
meanwhile they shut the cassandra's
house with
fireworks harassing you and your family
and that's like you're a liar yeah they
ran cover for the people who did it
and i had like police officers willing
to go on record saying it happened too
like
i know people in the dc police
department they were like clearly this
happened like we saw the fireworks we
found them
but yeah whatever happened what happened
to those people who ran that article
nothing for the rain cover really yeah
would you have been able to sue them
probably but but they they use clever
clever tactics
so a source familiar with the incident
told me it never happened oh and then
you're like who and i say i
don't have to give up my source you'll
sue for discovery and then there will be
no communications
you know you'll sue for defamation it'll
go to discovery there'll be no
communications and they can just assert
and say
i have a source and i will not reveal it
told me in an alley yeah yeah yeah i use
encrypted communications and i will not
share it you are here by instructed then
you can arrest me on the spot
and then they then they get paraded
around by left like there are true
journalists defending their sources it's
just the easiest way
there's a bunch of other clever things
too with like anti-slap laws
so slap laws are strategic lawsuits
against public participation
and that it's anti-slap meaning they
don't want
like the new york times and news outlets
to be sued
into oblivion because they criticize
people in power or billionaires
so the idea is if you're a public figure
they have to knowingly
defame you so it's called actual malice
the problem is
they do tons of clever things where they
they'll say like
when we have someone on the show i'll
give you i'll give you i'll give you a
general example of something that's
probably not
con controversial but can be you know so
let's say
i said something like remember when ian
told us
i have a pen yeah ian said i have a pen
they'll then say in an article tim poole
comma
who has said on his podcast i have a pen
comma
that phrase in and of itself is
meaningless but imagine if you were
quoting someone who said something
offensive
imagine if you were like can you believe
ian when he said
i don't like you know chocolate ice
cream
then what they'll do is they'll say you
know tim poole on his show who said
that and then they're gross yes i mean
it's it's it's how they
do it they won't say that you are
quoting someone when you and
and you can't sue them because it's true
you did say those words
yup oh logic logic defies reasons i
tried to
i well i did file a lawsuit against a
fusion reporter after the occasion oh
yeah
because i mean i hadn't even seen the
4chan meme everybody was doing the okay
sign because trump does it like when
he's making a point during a speech
right he'll be like okay you know
whatever and so everybody just started
doing it and we were
i was at the white house and i was
trolling and i was like oh we're taking
over this liberal space
so we took a picture it was you and
cernovich right yeah doing the okay sign
but it was like we were trolling in the
way like we're trump supporters in
you know your sacred little area not
like hey white power
right right puerto rican and cernovich
is married to a persian woman yeah
and so this woman from fusion
started tweeting that like we were
making the white power sign started
tweeting the 4chan memes and i was like
i've never even seen this and i think so
you ended up losing that
well yeah but they they ruled that she
did defame me
but that it was um i couldn't
win the defamation suit because i was
deliberately trolling on twitter oh
right
right right and so it was like oh there
you go yes i was trolling but i was
trolling a different way
but whatever we ended up i felt pursuing
it further it was easily provable that
she
knew she was lying because what this
what this uh i don't want to call her a
journalist
uh what she did was she took an image
from 4chan
a meme image from 4chan but then linked
something from the anti-defamation
league that showed something totally
different
so the anti-defamation league link
showed like a two-hand gesture maneuver
yeah but then she attached a 4chan meme
to it to make people think
they were the same thing she knew that
wasn't true unless she is the dumbest
person on the planet well now they still
claim that it is like it's everywhere
now like
everybody's like that means white power
and it's like the okay symbol
yeah i'm not gonna do it but it's
ridiculous so because when trump talks
he makes the the hand sign all the time
yeah you know
he's talking and he'll go like this with
his hands and so you i think it was
wasn't like milo
who started doing i think it was it was
somebody and then
4chan said let's make it a meme
where it's a it's a p and a w oh
and uh and these so here's here's the
thing right you you have
these individuals you know people like
gavin mcginnis
and uh other right-wing provocateurs i
guess i'm not saying gavin specifically
but they're all right-wing provocateurs
and they laugh at the idea that the
liberals are wrong
and they believe these fake things and
i'm just like
i don't think they actually believe it i
think they're laughing at you saying how
dumb of you to give us
ammunition and now they're laughing
they're sitting back their feet up you
know
they're just clipping their cigar and
smoking being like these guys are so
dumb they think they're trolling us
and we're using everything against them
and it works
meanwhile you have these right-wing
dudes laughing being like look they
really believe it means white power and
the journalist is like
i don't i just think it's going to
destroy your your politics
and it's going to give me political
power so thanks for doing that
and that's it they've got so many
clickbait stories out of that
every time that some random person
doesn't okay signing a picture they're
like
white supremacists at football game yeah
like
there was there was a picture of like
the basketball players
and and uh uh yeah they do the
three-pointer sign
yeah which is not necessarily the same
thing you hold up three fingers those
three fingers
and so they were like they're throwing
up white power and there was like this
i guess what happened was there was
something in the window of like a store
and then i guess they smashed the window
up because it was a basketball player
yelling three three pointer oh i
remember that these people are nuts
oh and then wasn't it uh the covington
kids when you remember remember the
covington kids
yeah so they're like on the stairs of
the lincoln you know memorial and the
native american guy shows up
people started posting photos from the
high school where in the basketball game
they're holding up the three-pointer
sign and they're like the
or white supremacists but here here's
what happens man
why was it that all of these mainstream
news outlets put out that fake story
about
nick sandman claiming he did this thing
he didn't do
they don't care if it's true or false
they care if it gets them clicks and it
makes them money
and then what happens is dude i know so
many
normies politically uninitiated people
who believe
the stupidest craziest insane stuff ever
it's blue and none
it's blue enough oh i love that phrase
me too it is
but like they're screaming that donald
trump staged an insurrection
and like you know i'm just like i know
but like what
what about when like the feminists
stormed into the the senate and you know
congressional buildings like three times
remember that text protecting them
though did you see urban dictionary took
uh blue and on out they put it back
oh they did they didn't put it back but
they did they took it down so this is
the craziest thing urban dictionary
which is supposed to be where you define
colloquial terms used in you know modern
settings deleted blue anon
because blue anon was basically saying
it is a reference to
democrat voters and individuals who
believe unhinged conspiracies about
russian collusion and that mobs and
militias are going to storm the capital
at any moment and they need razor wire
and so urban dictionary took it down
it's not it's it's not it's not hate
speech
it's not uh uh disparaging anybody based
on race or gender identity
they took it down because it's always
been political
it's politics i thought urban dictionary
was like where normal people would go
and kind of crowdsource the meaning of
these
up-and-coming you know the kids these
days are using these words
like yeet or whatever i don't know what
kids are saying these days
but i was like what foreign
yeah it's like to get rid of it yeah you
know i know unfortunately there's
another word
and you know all these these these
dangle kids they use the skull
emoji for laughing instead of though
like i'm dead yeah yeah
i died literally literally down show
on urban dictionary nonsense yeah yeah
but it there was a point where urban
dictionary started banning words that
were offensive
who runs that uh i don't know huh i mean
look at look at miriam i think it was
merriam-webster that changed
what we talked about this before they
changed the definition of gender to
create a paradoxical loop
oh yeah yes they put gender in the
definition right they put the word
gender in the definition of gender so
it's like
not becomes a paradox crazy do you
remember when maisie i'm sorry i'm sorry
i'm sorry i'm sorry
it comes it becomes an incur a curse of
a recursive loop
recursion recursion version yeah i think
so recursive loop yeah do you remember
when mazie hirono was saying that
saying the word sexual orientation were
offensive and merriam-webster went in
and changed it so that this was
obviously a pejorative
it'd never been before this is the the
so this is this is how it works man
there are a lot of people who need to
wake the f up
so we had we had clifton duncan on the
show the other day right he was like uh
he says broadway veteran classically
trained actor everybody apparently loved
the sound of his voice
oh yeah and he was talking about how
he's like a liberal guy
and he's still very liberal on policy
but he's like watching all this go down
and most people agree with him he's like
i gotta say something and speak up and
like now here he is on the show talking
about what's going on in his industry
and what he's experiencing
but there are a lot of people who don't
pay attention and they hear in the news
some insane thing like did you hear that
amy coney barrett said some like
like homophobic thing at the at the
trial whoa or
at the confirmation what did you say i
don't know it was like apparently that
caused a huge
like uproar like i can't believe she
said what she said and then also you
have all these normies who don't pay
attention just thinking she said
something when she literally didn't
what do you what do you guys think is
the best way to red pill
people like that i don't like the phrase
red pill yeah it's kind of vague
and it kind of insinuates it's abrupt
like because in neo when he takes the
red pill he's like shocked
into reality but i don't i don't want to
uh
necessarily entertain the concept that
one tribe has all the answers
necessarily yeah like when they say you
know red pills i
i say like sure but the people who use
the phrase red pill
aren't always right and i don't want to
be a tribal thing where you go to
someone
who might not agree with conservatives
like like clifton
clearly was not conservative and so his
world view is very very different from
people
who are conservative who are more likely
to use those phrases however that being
said
if we're into the fair assessment and
definition of what red pill is
i think michael malus's definition what
does he basically say when
white pilling no no red pill michael
mouse's definition of red pilling is
that when you realize the narrative the
corporate press
yeah is you know it's like the cathedral
is wrong they're right yeah they're
lying to you
corporate press so it's all about it's
all about looking past the corporate
press
it's it's it's remarkable when i have a
conversation with someone and they're
like
look man you know all these people
rioting and protesting yeah but trump
staged an insurrection
and i'm like they were banging on the
doors of the supreme court building when
kavanaugh was there
they changed the definitions in
dictionaries to smear the supreme court
justices they don't like
they the women in the pink hats
literally stormed into the congressional
buildings occupying every floor and got
congress shut down
when was that yeah that was the day of
the kavanaugh hearing 2018
yeah i filmed the left storming congress
a
bunch of times it happens all the time
happens frequently i mean i was talking
to one of my friends who's a
officer in dc and he was like man it was
bad it was bad and i was like yeah but
this happens
all the time like how many times have i
filmed them storming the capitol
building
like i lost my press pass because i was
filming people storming the capitol
building wow but that's not that i was
with them
that's why it's crazy that ashley
babbitt was shot yeah and right now
i guess her represent her family and
their representation is saying
there was no threat to that guy on the
other side of the door
no one had breached the door she was
standing up to look through the window
and he was not threatened with anything
she was not flashing anything he just
saw her face not only that
there were cops apparently below that
allowed those people to go up the stairs
and i don't know i don't know how true
that is but i do know in the video you
watched the cops like
walk up right after she got shot they're
there they were literally there
so it's remarkable that you can have all
these women storm
into which building was it it was like
it was all of them i think it was i know
it wasn't
i filmed it in heart right right right
right in the rock on every floor
there was a bunch of buildings yeah and
they shut did it shut down congress
yeah i believe so they don't call it an
insurrection they didn't say it was an
insurrection they
say it was well they were fighting for
women's rights
didn't they get into the elevator with
congressmen and scream at them in their
faces would that not be considered and
those elevators are for
congressmembers that was wild it's
making me think about
the corporate press and the whole don't
question the vote
and it's all like don't question the
vote
it's don't question the vote online
because we'll ban your account
don't question the vote at the capitol
because hold on don't even show
donald trump speaking at cpac don't
quote him saying it they banned rsb
they suspended rspn for two weeks and
gave him a strike for simply
showing donald trump speaking that's
insane ford fisher
journalist he he his footage of donald
trump speaking
on january 6 was used by a bunch of news
outlets because he licenses it out
they banned him they they apparently
like
suspended not banned they suspended his
channel gave him a strike meanwhile the
new york times and his other outlets
used the exact
same footage so i think what we're
seeing is
it's it's not so much about the rules
are meaningless
what it really is they're waiting
they're sitting there saying we only
want corporate establishment press
we want the cathedral's narrative to be
the only narrative
however they need an excuse to ban
people
they there was a lot of there are a lot
of problems when they started randomly
banning people and it led to huge press
cycles of like why was this person
banned didn't break any rules
then you get people all tweeting like
crazy we demand you reinstate them and
then they're pressured into reinstating
people
but when you see someone get banned and
then they say
you posted a video that broke this rule
it's definitive i'll tell you this
i've had people hit me up and they're
like yo tim my channel got shut down
i don't know why can you help me out and
i'm like for sure
what happened they say this video got
taken down and now i can't upload
and then i look at the video and i'm
like you you showed that news story
like if if i send this to google and say
hey this is incorrect they're going to
say no it's not we said you can't show
that news story
it's probably bunk it's probably a bs
reason
but it's like what you know what real
argument do you have for like a big
boycott or a big push
when they they broke the rule
so certainly we still push back and say
that that shouldn't be a rule you should
be allowed to express your opinion and
say what you want to say but from a
technical standpoint
you end up with some low-level google
employee that like i might
be able to email or have access to and
they're going to be like i just can't
override my boss the rules are the rules
we told everybody in january you can't
say these things
or show these things in any context so
now donald trump's speeches are being
removed
ultimately i think it's gonna be really
really good for trump
i think it's gonna be really good for
trump i mean look what happened at dr
seuss books they banned him and now
they're like thousands of dollars yeah
wow yeah so like people the more you
bend something the more people want to
hear it
but it's always going to be that way i
think with trump one of the biggest
problems he had was that he couldn't
keep his mouth shut
it benefited him a lot of ways his
ability to control the narrative and
bypass the press really angered the
press
but they're addicted to him they're
still addicted to him they're calling it
the trump slump now
because ratings across the board have
been collapsing layoffs are happening
media's falling apart
but now if trump comes back and runs
again
he can directly email everybody but that
is a lot more arduous than a tweet
you've like we get these emails now
everyone's like i guess getting them
from the office of the 45th
and i don't even know how my emails are
in that system but he got him he
got my email and now it's just going
direct to my mailbox
but think about this he's not gonna be
able to tweet or go on youtube and say
anything
so the only thing that will come from
trump is going to be the
like purest distilled version of trump
without the the nonsensical tweets
calling someone horse face i mean unless
he hops on parlor or something
which he should mike he sure should i
mean he's got to be careful about
drawing the ire of the isps
be cool to see him start up his own isp
and social network isn't mike lindell he
is yeah i have that article pulled up
actually
is he really that he is my pillow uh
my pillow ceo mike lindell says he is
launching his own social media site in
the next four or five weeks
after being barred from twitter for
election fraud claims
now i'll tell you this mike lindell
wasn't just barred from twitter what did
like
rsbn was he was being interviewed and
they turned his mic off
yeah and on uh newsmax one of the
anchors stormed off because michael
adele wouldn't stop talking about
the election and you know you know like
the crazy thing is man look
with all due respect crowder even talked
about the claims mike lindell has made
and he's like i'm sorry someone gave him
bad information it's just not true
because like a lot of the stuff mike
lindell put out i guess is what crowder
was saying
some of the counties where he claimed
impropriety happened
don't even use dominion voting machines
and crowder confirmed that
granted crowder did his own
investigation where he found crazy stuff
he found that's the thing though like
the mainstream media pushed the russia
hoax
for years like and we we can't censor
them
so why should he be censored even if
he's knowingly putting out false
information which i don't think is the
case
but even if he was he has a right to do
that everybody has a right to lie
you're it lying is not illegal well it's
still first amendment protected speech
it is yep the the the government has
outsourced censorship
to corporations it's how you it's yeah
it's how you destroy the constitution
so what you see in like uh it's a
scaling problem for sure
think about like the 1700s when you had
you know i guess what do they have
flintlock pistols
and muskets and you're walking around
this small town the buildings aren't
very big the population's not
particularly dense but you can be armed
and everybody you know a lot of people
typically were
well until the red coat started seizing
people's weapons which
you know led to part of the you know a
lot of the revolution a lot of the
sentiment towards it
but now look at chicago for instance
ridiculously dense
buildings everywhere massive buildings
and on every building in chicago there's
a sign
with a gun and a you know circle around
in a line going through it you can't
bring weapons in here
so even though you have the right to
bear arms
not on private property now i can
respect that if someone's got a store
and they're like i don't want you to
come in here with a gun
because we got to deal with burglars
whatever and i don't know who i'm
supposed to trust and i don't want to i
don't want to deal with it
that i get you can go to the next store
but what happens when there's one store
what if there was only like you guys
have seen idiocracy where they still
haven't
what what was it like costco costco that
was once
good i love you yeah so they show like
so it's 500 years in the future mike
judge is a genius by the way and
uh they're going to the store and it's
this
massive like multi-square mile mass you
know costco
and it's just that's the future but what
if that was the only place you could go
to get resources and they wouldn't let
you speak
any say anything or bear arms the issue
is
well if i have to go into this place
like imagine if a private company
bought all of the land in chicago and
then if you wanted to walk into the city
you you lost all your constitutional
rights like that's the problem
because facebook and these websites are
in virtual spaces
they're getting away with doing it you
know republicans weren't smart
republican politicians
were too stupid to do anything about it
but i'll tell you this i think the
republican politicians for the most part
are what's the right word for it they're
like dangling keys
to keep republicans distracted who was
it who was reading dr seuss recently
kevin mccarthy yeah kevin mccarthy wow
very he didn't even read one of the
brave
exactly so brave killed me but think
about this
that's that's what you voted for he's
reading he's reading one of these books
didn't they ban green eggs in him no
really yeah no that's not that's like
the most wholesome book yeah okay okay
so that's what he does what was he doing
and and correct me if i'm wrong
but uh or if i'm out of out of turn and
saying so
where was he when they were tearing down
statues where where was he when across
the country
where was he when in wisconsin black
lives matter rioters tore down a statue
of hans christian hagg a civil war hero
who fought to and he was an abolitionist
who fought to end slavery and he gave
his life doing so
where where were these republicans a few
of them spoke out
right absolutely but look are we gonna
sit here and be like thomas massey and
rand paul are cool dudes i don't like
lumping them in with like
mitch mcconnell yeah yeah they're very
different they're unique
yeah he's great i don't know but i i
like him he's great
he's one of my favorites yeah maybe they
should start a new party uh it's sick
but then
they don't win and so i certainly think
they need to do a new party but trump is
like we're not going to do it
why it would work if the left did it too
if the left started
progressive democrats but do you saw
what just happened in nevada
yeah wow let me let me actually
do we have this one pulled up or not i
think we do i thought we did
no we don't let me see if i can pull
something up jump to it yeah
if we had two new parties then they
could go like the
that's how lincoln got into office
there's a four-party run that year
check this out oh this is cool nevada
democratic party staff
quits and mass after socialists win
leadership
roles that's the news the democratic
card-carrying members of the democratic
socialists won leadership positions in
nevada
so the entire like staff from the party
quit
why sour grapes uh i mean i gotta be
honest
like would you want to have the party
leaders be socialized
what's card carrying social is there
literally like a socialist party
democratic socialist of america and
they're dues paying members so when i
say card-carrying member i mean they
literally pay dues to the organization
to be an official member i don't know if
they actually get cards or anything
are they hardcore socialist like oh
let's let's give the
what means the production of the state
or is that communist that's communist no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no no no no no no no no that's social
media production they're they're very
very similar communism and socialism
socialism paves the way
yeah yeah communism is i mean
they're almost identical it's almost
interchangeable but the democratic
socialists
think that we should have full-on
seizing the means of production
so long as people vote for it oh
to to a certain to a certain extent
democratic communism
i'm fine with people voting for what
they want and it creates a problem if
everybody in the country wants socialism
and other people don't i mean that's how
our system works
the problem is the tactics they use to
get what they want lying cheating and
stealing for sure
and ignorance manipulation right right
and
and and i can already hear this the
screams and the squeals of democratic
socialists
saying but what about republicans and
the consumers in the far right and i'm
like
yes okay what about us moving on
what annoys me about the democratic
socialists is that they're
i align with them pretty hard on foreign
policy
and then it's like they'll say something
that makes perfect sense and i'm like oh
wow this person like
gets it and they're leftist cool and
then i read their
rest of their tweets and i'm like oh
okay they're crazy though right right
there's too much so i i saw something on
reddit where was from
bernie sanders subreddit and it said it
was basically the meme that was like
you know joe biden's dropping a lot of
bombs for someone owes me two thousand
dollars
and i'm like yes like i think 85 of
people in this country agree
stop blowing up kids and start giving
out checks yeah and biden
just like i love that meme where
robotnik's just gleefully smashing the
vaporized syrians button
so the problem i think there's there's
there's there's two problems
i do think a lot of these dsa types
do you guys see did you you saw the
meeting of the dsa that went viral oh
um you saw this a while ago right yeah
where six months ago where it's like
they can't stop fighting over their
identities
oh yeah like stop saying guys you said
hey guys don't say that it's like jazz
yeah everyone's doing jazz hands um
clapping is triggering people's anxiety
and then the guy gets really mad like i
told you it's making me anxious and like
it's really great i'm sure that's on
youtube so wonderful yeah yeah
it's it's a really awful thing it's like
how are you gonna function in society if
you're doing things like this
but i i appreciate the uh anti-war stuff
especially
the problem is that weird creepy
critical theory
identity based stuff that is just
when i see that stuff i really just
it looks like you know what's what's
that what's that
fabric you use for like when you're
moving stuff and it's like
it's just like a bunch of lint mashed
together moving blankets yeah and it's
all just like various bits of fabric
that were just pressed particle board
it's almost like particles yeah and
that's what i see on like all of these
random things there's no unification
there's no unity there's no structure
they're all just randomly pressed in
here yelling at each other about how
their identity is wrong and their
identity is wrong and obama called it a
circular firing squad
yeah i could see it maybe that's why
their whole platform is like opposing
things they don't actually seem to have
real coherent policies they just want to
fight everything that the right wing is
doing i think that's true for everybody
though
yeah kevin macarthy's reading dr seuss
dude
that's part of why i don't like ant the
term anti-war because i feel like it's
just opposing something but
rather than focusing on a new structure
that war is not a part of
you know like i don't know drone
delivery of food and water
yeah maybe maybe we need to get away
from this anti-thing because the
opposite of war is not anti-war it's
not war you know what i mean right it's
peace
so maybe we need to stop saying you know
we they're for war we're against war it
should just be like we're for peace
this is what we are for this is what
we're pushing peace you know not
like that not not this kind of combat
stuff instead
i guess what do we get there's that meme
where like the bombers are dropping it's
like republicans as a regular military
jet and democrats has like a rainbow
flag on it and it's like
dropping a bomb on kids and yeah that's
that's about it bombing the middle east
with diversity yes
there was there was there's a funny name
i just saw someone said i can't believe
they did the meme
they did yeah and it was it was biden in
like the office saying like here's your
you know like new military leadership
and it's like a woman of color or
something
and then they're like showing the meme
where it's two middle eastern people as
if dramas bopped on them
what did i say you said a drama
and they're like they're like i'm you
know it's so exciting that we're being
bombed by a woman
history yeah yeah we're part of history
that's great they totally did it they
did that meme
well so anyway like back to the you know
the democrats quitting or whatever oh
yeah
i don't know i think the democratic
party is collapsing i think the the life
tests are winning
is this going to start happening more
often definitely okay and the worrying
thing about it in my opinion is that i
mean dude i
i think socialism is bad there's a big
difference between between like social
policy and socialism
and what they do is they'll either
because
a lot of their members are ignorant or
because they're willfully manipulating
people
they'll say denmark is a socialist
country and look how well they're doing
right and then you're like they're
they're a capitalist system with a
welfare structure
socialism is seizing the means of
production and they're all so much
smaller
right and less populated than we are
very humble exactly exactly
but so when they say you know these
countries are socialist and they're not
their capitalists and even denmark said
bernie stop calling a socialist or not
bernie actually has proposed seizing the
means of production he proposed 20
of all corporate shares being held for
him for the employees of the company to
receive dividends and bonuses and stuff
like that
and it's it's it's it's like oh okay
that's an interesting idea
i think companies should implement that
on their own
but it's one step towards we're giving
20 to the company to the people
so owning the means of production then
eventually
the dsa people they tell you they're
social democrats
social democrats are the people who are
like you choose what you buy
you choose you know where you work you
choose where you go to school you save
your money you buy the things you like
but you'll be taxed a lot for health
care for military for police or fire
that's social social democrats that's
like scandinavian countries
the dsa is straight up just like sees
the means of production
for you know z and zer so what happens
when the democrats
in nevada they quit and now party
leadership is all dsa
what happens in you know five years four
or five years
when large swaths of the democratic
party have been taken over by
the far left trump supporters are going
to be like no
no just not happening so when you have
the uniparty
between the corporate dems and the
corporate republicans this is all their
fault by the way
they did nothing they extracted from the
system they blew people up they milked
it for all it was worth
and it led to people getting extremely
angry which leads to
right-wing populism and lifting populism
these two tribes
are further away than the uniparty was
and if the establishment dems and
republicans actually
listened to the people and actually
worked on things say not bailing out big
banks
like stopping them from this mass
conglomeration of these banks which
made them too big to fail which led to
occupy wall street
which leads to riots and then you get a
left and right version of populism
i think trump has already taken over the
republican party
it's it's it's says yes you know there's
a lot of republicans who are
weak and pathetic and will probably be
voted out at some point the republican
party has become the party of trump
everybody seems to agree so that's it
now the democratic party needs to become
the party of bernie or the democratic
socialists
at that point it's basically we have two
political parties anti-fun the proud
boys
and then what happens there's going to
be someone in congress caning the other
guy
okay and then what happened what country
was that where they were like jumping in
britain is in britain
you have to keep your toes behind the
line too in parliament
they have like stuff up man because
people would fight now honestly
mutual combat in congress not totally
against
it you gotta put it on tv
pelosi and schumer yes let's go my money
is on marjorie taylor green
too she'll jump on people like
spider-man well but but is it but is it
republican versus democrat or is it
everyone versus
anyone that wants to tangle yeah wow
just throw your hat in wild west
royal rum yeah i would i would i would
bet margaery taylor green near the top
but you've also got you know dan
crenshaw yep i don't know people don't
like east yeah
but a commander but he was you know he's
not that old he's just not he's just
yeah
don't mess with x military tom cotton
yeah lauren bobert's armed yeah
so she'll win really quickly aoc is a
puerto rican right
oh yeah so she's tough that's puerto
rican yeah
i'll give her a little bit of credit i
don't know i think
i think aoc would be tough she seems
like tough maybe she might be scrappy
i definitely think so yeah she's at
least a sword reacan i think so
i think nancy pelosi should be the first
one banging the door help saying
screaming help me she's so old to break
her hip
mitch mcconnell would actually survive
the longest because he would retreat
into his shell he would yes
that's part of it but they wouldn't do
it because it was a mutual combat so you
just get these young upstarts that
prove themselves can't take it anymore
super old people it
it is funny but i do think that if you
end up with and i mean it somewhat
facetiously the party of antifun the
party of the proud boys
like they're gonna start boxing each
other the problem is bernie i think
the democrats should be the party of
bernie and probably things would be
going a lot smoother if
it was but the media was totally against
it that this established like
warmongering
community wanted hillary in and they
wanted biden and it's
it's the way i see it is you've got this
you know uh body of water flowing
and instead and they're trying to damn
the river with
sheer force immediately to stop the tide
of bernie sanders
instead they could have you know used
controls to shift the flow and have some
control over what was going on i
legitimately believe they fortified the
election against barney
like i mean they said they did yeah i
don't i do not believe
well i'm trying to isolate the correct
term from time magazine
against bernie oh against bernie yeah i
fully believe that i mean but no we know
this from 2016. this is this is
undisputed they gave cnn you know cnn
gave hillary clinton the questions that
donna brazile stuff
and uh this time around time magazine
wrote that article and they said
the the plan began in fall of 2019 well
before
the democratic primaries bernie was on
fire yeah and then iowa who won iowa i
guess that was just like
and then all of a sudden all of the
democrat all the democrats
quit and then endorsed biden yes and
then elizabeth warren who was like
siphoning bernie's voters
for the last couple days yup so weird i
think that they cheated him in 2016
though like i legitimately think that he
won
i'm like crazy why did i see that
on this like the actual numbers they
were just like yeah we're just going to
give you different numbers i don't i
don't think so
i know that they well listen listen in
the emails they were trying to
discredit him based on his race and say
you look at hillary's emails it was a
little disturbing
the i think that i call it ocean's
elevening
it's like they they fortify it i i
really do think fortify is the right
word to be completely it's the safest
word that's first no but but hear me out
like i in in fall in in october of 2019
pennsylvania changed the voting rules
for mail-in voting so that's like the
rules were
were changed and there's a legal
challenge as to whether whether or not
they were allowed to do it right that
never got
resolved so call it what you want but
fortifying basically means people who
supported joe biden
fortified the things that would give joe
biden the win so
we actually had sean parnell on the show
and he was talking about mail and voting
and i said do you think they're doing
this you know to like
give them an advantage and he said
they're doing these things
because they think it will help them win
and they're right
i know i know a lot of people i was
shocked to find this you know what was
surprising to me there are some people
who told me they were voting for trump
and then only afterwards they admitted
they voted for biden
there there are a lot of people i know
who don't care about politics
there's this one guy i know who is like
has no business being in politics
because he is one of the dumbest people
i've ever met he's just some
skateboarder guy and all of a sudden now
he's like ranting about things that
don't make sense
and he's like we need a 24 minimum wage
and i'm like that's even more than what
that people are arguing for they're
under 15. you're like way above
everybody else but there are articles
saying this
and the guys only become political once
the election got fortified
and they were ramping up the rhetoric
and then telling everybody what for
riling them up and saying these things
and there were a lot of people who are
like
hillary has to win we can't have you
know we can't have bernie hillary has to
win
and so when you control the corporate
press
i mean we're just talking about this
when you can lie and falsely frame
things clever tactics
and regular people who don't pay
attention are sitting in like their work
room and they see on tv something where
it's like donald trump you know kicked a
puppy in the face
and it's clearly false but they
passively hear it and then and then one
day
there's like this guy and he's like i'm
not gonna vote for trump he kicked that
puppy and then the person goes
oh yeah i guess i won't i wouldn't do
that either they push the fake news the
manipulation the lies and the narrative
fortify really is i think a good word
for it because i think
i think one of one of the things i don't
like about this idea that anybody really
got cheated is just that
i don't think the people who control all
the corporations
uh the people who control massive
multinational corporations people like
zuckerberg
they don't need to like sneak into the
back room they need
only drop a million bucks in the right
direction
this is why i you know another another
area where i really agree
with the left is citizens united is bad
i don't like the idea that people can
spend endless amounts of money on super
pacs and packs
i don't like the idea that george soros
or the mercers or the koch brothers or
mackenzie bezos can be like we're
billionaires
so we can dictate the flow of
information i don't like the idea that
michael bloomberg
goes and dumps hundreds of millions of
dollars across the country
to guarantee that progress like
progressives and democrats win that's
subverting democracy
and he does it in the name of gun
control so i'm like we need to have some
restrictions i'll tell you this
a lot of people have said to me but tim
there's a limit on how much you can
donate to someone
you can only give i think what 2 300
bucks or something yeah so what happens
when you're tom steyer and you're like
okay i can only give 2 300 bucks but i
can give 2 300 bucks to literally every
single progressive running
well that's clearly going to have a
major impact you can buy ad space
you can buy you know you can buy air
time and get access
the republicans can't granted you still
had you know i guess the mercers were
funding a lot of stuff you do have those
interests as well
i don't like any of it could i
theoretically
donate 2 300 to a candidate and then
make a commercial
supporting the candidate and get the
candidate to say i support this message
at the end of it
and then that money that i spent on the
commercial would not count towards the
23. no you can't do that okay that would
count as a donation so what what you
would do is you make a commercial where
you're like cassandra fairbanks is the
best candidate for this country yes
this ad was paid for by ian crossland
like cassandra fairbanks
that would not be a donation so i could
do as many of those as i wanted so
the idea with citizens united is that
you're allowed to say whatever you want
you have free speech
if you want to buy ad space and say you
like a candidate you're allowed to do it
now fundamentally i do agree with that
right to free speech
if i want to buy a commercial where i
explain why why i like a certain
candidate
i should be allowed to do it this is
where the challenge comes in the reason
why i don't have a real solution for
this problem is that
so what so what i have this big show and
i can talk about why tulsi gabbard is so
great giving her
massive press and attention but you ian
you know
you don't have that show so you don't
get to do that that's why
citizens united basically stood because
it's like well it's not fair that
someone who has access to the media
gets to dictate and other people don't
you see what i mean
yeah it goes back i was reading a little
bit about it goes back to like the i
think the 1800s when um
they used to kind of keep money out of
politics like explicitly they were
really anti like they didn't want to pay
i think ben franklin didn't even want to
pay congress people at all
um but one guy was running for i think
president and was like why can't i use
my own money to pay for my
my thing i wanted i want to take the
train around the country and spend all
my when they were like yeah that's a
good point
it's your money you should be able to do
whatever you want with it so he used it
to fund his campaign
and that was kind of the precedent for
it's a challenge the challenge is
i've talked a lot i've talked to a lot
of people about this i don't like the
idea that big billionaires can just dump
money
and they can just crush shut everybody
down but then it doesn't
that the problem is like i mentioned so
what you know jenk yogurt the young
turks will have access to all of these
millions of people to tell them what to
think and
no one can challenge that no one else
because even right now you can have
people pull their money together to buy
a commercial and that's
what a lot of political action
committees do so it's tough
how do we solve that problem i honestly
don't know i don't know
because like influence is not money
money can buy you influence or buy you
the opportunity to produce influence but
making a video online is also money
can't buy that like that's that
and there would be too much speech you'd
have to regulate to actually
shut down billionaires buying influence
how do we keep it from becoming a
popularity contest
that's what it is concerns me a lot
because you get stupid people that are
really popular
in there which i feel like we're staring
at right now no it isn't
stupid it's a little harsh but
unintelligent low information
not the best yeah not the smartest low
information people
are uh that's that's the ticket for
democrats winning
with a shiny haircut and you know i said
it before and i'll say it again
it's not to disparage democrats but 16
year olds are not high information
voters
and democrats wanting to pass was hr one
has a provision a lower the voting age
to 16
those are not high information voters 16
year olds would literally be the lowest
possible information voters you could
get it's not their fault
and i don't i i i maybe i'm already
hearing the 16 year olds yell
there's a few of them out there they're
probably way smarter than the rest of us
right so there's a
it's it's an issue of experience
knowledge and wisdom
and i am being i don't want to say
stereotypical
but uh i think it's fair to say that
somebody who is 20 has
is is typically going to have more life
experience
than a 16 year old not always true
actually you know like i had my first
job when i was a little kid in my
family's business
and i didn't go to high school and i
meet people who haven't had jobs they're
26.
yeah so clearly like when i was 16 i was
more qualified to vote than
some of these 26 year olds but it's a
tendency and
you know it's i guess a challenge to
figure out
where we draw the line but i think we
have a pretty good line right now
you're 18. you can enter a contract you
join the military i think i think the
drinking and smoking age should be
should be the same yeah yeah if you can
die for the country you can have a beer
like that's crazy
but i think that that makes sense the
point though is that democrats strive
on those who have no idea what's going
on i think we should raise the voting
age to 21 instead of lowering i think
you're right and the military age
yeah they should all be the same they
should be higher i guess five
i would i would put it up to 25 or 30
honestly yeah
the voting age 35 but also joining the
military
i don't think we should be shipping
babies off to war grade i think that we
should
you know you should have had to pay
taxes and deal with things before you're
voting
but the the thing is back in the day an
18 year old was
an adult right like not anymore legit an
adult yeah but that's not the case
probably in kids
yeah yeah yeah well well back in the day
people wouldn't live much past 65 either
and that's
cause it's huge so it's caused well so
when they put you know
social security into effect they were
like well this will be like
if people make it to this age they're
lucky there won't be many of them no
there's a misconception okay so
experience the lower life expectancy was
due to infant mortality not due to how
long
i think benjamin franklin lived to be
like 80 something so if you survived
past childhood
you would typically live to be in your
70s so why did we set it to 65
uh wasn't it wasn't it way earlier and
we keep pushing it back
like wasn't the retirement age like way
lower before i don't know
i don't know i thought it started at 65.
i believe it's getting pushed back
we are weird it definitely is it's
consistently being pushed back but i
mean
the problem is it was really interesting
when we talked to ben stewart about
strass how generational theory
because he was he he said the book
basically points out when all of these
boomers are eligible to collect social
security
there's going to be a crisis because
where's our money going to come from
because it ain't there
just print it yeah and then all of a
sudden we had this major collapse
it's going to be crazy when uh
millennials reach social security age
like
it's going to be a bunch of look the
thing is you're going to have
the you're going to have gen you're
going to have baby boomers gen x
and millennials well actually i guess
so millennials are what 35 now so it's
another 30 years before they hit that
that number at that point the boomers
are probably going to be
mostly on the way out so you're going to
have gen x and boomers screaming at gen
z to pay up
we want that money and we got this life
extension have you guys been studying
the harvard life extension stuff
nicotine about mononucleosis yeah you
should probably look into getting david
sinclair in the show sometime he's a
genius how long are people living with
that though well
actually according to them yeah it you
longer and they give he was giving to
his dog the dogs are living without
it's still in early studies but i mean
hypothetically 130 you'll be in 80
you'll look like you're 80 when you're
130 and then it's just going to keep
getting longer so we're gonna
the boomers will be around for a lot
longer than we anticipated
and so on so it might very well be
boomers gen x and millennials all
screaming
they deserve a social security check and
then what happens when you have boomers
who are getting checks for 30 years if
they all start living to be 19. it's
crazy that the incentive to stop paying
them is
for them to die like what kind of system
have we built how do we just stop
foreign aid
that would help right take care of our
citizens i don't know dr
seuss says that you're a bigot oh yeah
don't get me started
i was gloating a little bit when he got
canceled to be honest everybody was like
cassandra no we need you on our side
you're like pro free speech and i'm like
yeah but he was like one of the original
cancelers
it's true but i will i will say like he
was definitely a war propagandist
we had when we talked with michael malus
about this and he made good points about
world war one
that it was like what was the like
seriously what was the main point who
who were we fighting why were there
these
alliances and it was basically just a
large war and it's like okay then maybe
there's a good point to be made there
about
war propaganda is pushing us to join
world war one but world war ii i think
was pretty clear-cut
no you don't think so no not at all and
i actually
would have been on the side of not um
intervening in world war ii
but what actually was going on in 1939
1940
was there was a bipartisan push against
war and it wasn't because they supported
hitler or because they didn't want to
rescue the jewish people
the the issue was that they didn't
believe that you should be fighting wars
for europe
because we were a separate nation we
were on a different continent we weren't
in any danger
and so the belief was which it was
bipartisan like very bipartisan there
were socialists that were far right
like everybody was in it walt disney was
a funder
um they they just didn't think that
you know united's children american
children should be fighting
european wars and you have to remember
that
at the in the early stages of this
people didn't even know about the
concentration camps they didn't know
about what was happening in germany
and so the argument wasn't about whether
or not we should intervene it was
should we help europe right and so
people opposed it
of course when pearl harbor happened all
the people who were in america first
committee and other
anti-intervention groups immediately
were like oh forget this like of course
yes sign me up we'll go fight
now we've been attacked right but the
issue wasn't
it wasn't clear-cut back then because
there were a half million people who
joined the america first committee which
was
opposition to intervention and
what dr seuss was fighting was the
isolationist views of americans because
a lot of americans were isolationists
after world war one
right they were still grieving people
they were still suffering effects of
having been in the war
they didn't want to go into another war
and so they had to make it seem like all
these people were racist
and and that's what doctors did
the yeah comic is that there's a guy who
has america first and his beard is
connected to a nazi
yeah i have a whole book of all his war
propaganda and it was good i mean it's
the same stuff that they use now
right it literally is the same thing
that they do to anti-war people now
or you know pro-peace people now i'll
tell you though there's a real challenge
with in my opinion with world war ii
because as much as i think what we're
doing in the middle east is complete
garbage and trash
and i love the abraham accords if we
didn't intervene in world war i
excuse me world war ii a strong
possibility i guess it's fairly likely
to say
nazis would have won and then all of
these horrifying things they were doing
would would have persisted and so with
that in mind i look at what china is
doing now and i feel much the same way
but again see here's the thing here's
the real test as much as i can be like
well look i wasn't alive during world
war ii
i can certainly understand why it was
good that we went in
and stormed the beaches of normandy
d-day surrounded
you know germany shut down hitler now i
look at china and like
it's it's it's real now it's not looking
back in a history book
now it's there's actually a question of
tim are you saying you would support a
military intervention
into china to stop their concentration
camps and i'm like wow
because what i think people need to
realize is we can look back at what
happened in world war ii and think it's
so easy to make that choice
because we know we won now we're looking
at china
and we're looking at the concentration
camps and there's the real consideration
of we don't know what will happen
it could be all out nuclear annihilation
between everybody
but how do we stop those concentration
camps there's always unintended
consequences
of even a good intentioned intervention
i mean look at
dresden like people don't like to talk
about it but read slaughterhouse five
read about what happened and what people
went through there they we
leveled the whole city you know um yeah
dresden got firebombed and
300 000 people i think they would create
a vacuum
under the fire like the whole city was
on flames and it would create underneath
just this vacuum that would suck people
in and up into the flames yeah it was
gruesome
i mean it's horrific to read about what
happened there and people like to memory
hole it and just think oh we were heroes
we did good
and that's not necessarily i mean it is
true but you
you know there are bad consequences of
it as well
and it's always always the case look
what happened in libya
we went in we're like hey we're heroes
now now there's open slave trade
um there's there's always unintended
consequences of intervention and i
don't think that people uh
really put enough thought into it people
are just like oh it's good we stopped
the holocaust
but then they don't think about the fact
that you know dresden happened and all
these other things
so there's a sadness to it even though
we won
you know what i mean well i think uh
yeah i agree especially with all these
other countries
libya especially like man did we really
did the united i hate saying we the
united states
really screwed that up hillary clinton
we came we saw he died
sydney blumenthal her friend sid
according to hillary with his osprey
global solutions weapons manufacturing
company to arm the new
american-backed rebellion like just just
total
arms running to make money a profiteer
another biden bombing in syria here we
go again so there's
there's there's a big challenge like i
was saying you know we look back on
world war ii
and we're like of course it was great
but because we know we won
what if we what if we lose what if we
lost now we're looking at china and
these concentration camps
and you know many of us are saying they
can't be doing this what do we do to
stop it
and the first first thing i'll say is
where is any
politician to be screaming in the senate
chamber
the united states should cut off
business with china while they're
operating concentration camps
instead what do we get well uh democrats
view them as partners
as partners disney says thank you to the
paramilitary who is operating
concentration camps
and jo and we need our president
to demand that congress pass legislation
saying the u.s will not do business with
china that might lead to war
it will lead to war but isn't it better
that we go from an economic approach and
say we're not going to start a conflict
we're killing each other but you have to
stop concentration camps i mean
economic warfare will lead to boots on
the ground it will lead to people dying
it's
the way it always has been do we just i
mean pearl harbor
a lot of that was over you know
sanctions and weapons
and gas being sent to europe and stuff
well it was uh the u.s sanctioning japan
yeah and so
i think that there's consequences for
these things i think that
you know economic warfare is still
warfare and it's going to lead to death
no matter what happens
i agree but how do we how do we how do
we then what do we do
like we can't keep doing business with
china while they're operating
concentration camps i don't know if it's
our job to be the world's police though
i'm all for you know promoting made in
america products
i think that we should bring
manufacturing home i think we should
incentivize that big time
but i also am not sure i necessarily
agree with
the u.s having to get involved in every
conflict there's horrendous things
happening
all over the world every day that's true
and we can't save everybody we can't
and there's a lot going on in a lot of
these african nations with these
extremist groups that are kidnapping
little girls
and that's a good point uh a lot of
anti-war people do point out especially
like
end of war left says people get really
focused on china these concentration
camps
like why aren't you talking about what's
going on in like nigeria and things like
that
yeah the media and our government want
us to care about
it's the same reason people cared so
much about venezuela it's because they
the u.s government wanted to go in and
you know
overturn get them on the opec dollar
right and so
they make you care about certain
atrocities right but there's atrocities
everywhere
and we can't do everything we need to
fix our own
nation we're kind of screwed right now
there's homeless people everywhere
there's we have enough problems
we need to fix our problems before we
try and save the whole world
they tell us that every day on a plane
you know every time you fly secure your
mask before securing the mask of those
sitting next to you take a plank out of
your own eye before trying to remove the
mode of dust out of your friends
is that the same thing that's what jesus
said that oh
it's remarkable to me that we are a
country that in the midst of a pandemic
with a massive economic collapse
we gave away like hundreds of hundreds
of millions of dollars to foreign
countries
it's like yo like a bunch of people are
like out of work and gonna be evicted
why are we giving money away my favorite
move on that whole thing was paul gasar
he figured out how much 1.9 trillion
how much that would be divided just
among americans who need it
that's ten thousand dollars almost and
so he put in the bill and amendment to
give all americans ten thousand dollars
to take out all the foreign aid because
that's how much they would get for
him out of the foreign aid that would've
been something man if everyone got 10
grand
yeah but it would lead to hyperinflation
right because we did it anyway
we just gave it out absolutely
absolutely yeah and still going to infl
you know
it would have yeah the issue now is
here's the best part
those us dollars being sent to these
foreign countries they get spent
on on american stuff so instead of
giving money to an american citizen
they give money to a foreign or a
foreign government who then contracts
and says now do work for us to the
american citizen get it
well it's lockheed martin it's a welfare
program for for our military industrial
complex
as far as i can tell it's the bank of
international settlements that's
choosing to print the money out of the
u.s
federal reserve so that it's the same
global money
they're just making it in the guys of
the american dollar instead of the
british
pound or the australian whatever they
use in australia maybe they use the
pound as well yeah they just chose to
print it out of the u.s to hyperinflate
the u.s economy
so they're using us of course and then
they're sending our money all over the
world these the politicians are so maybe
they're in cahoots or maybe they're just
stupid
we're in we're in an economic collapse
your business was shut down
then your politician gave money that you
paid into
to a different country that country then
orders something from america they can
use dollars maybe it's oil
or maybe it's like some software
manufacturing or service in america
so now here you are as the american
citizen being told you have to do work
for
say you know like yemen because they
receive you know military aid or
something
and you're like i'm so desperate for
work my government didn't give me a
stimulus check
and then you hear some foreign
corporation is hiring people to do a
certain job and you're like oh please
give me work
the government gave your money away to
someone else and then told you to go
work for them
that's nuts to me because that's that's
what they'll do with it with that money
admittedly i think they'll mostly buy
oil with it because the petrol dollar if
they want to you know buy oil gotta
trade in that
but there are a lot of like what can you
really do with u.s dollars there are
many countries that aren't america that
actually use the us dollars their
official currency it's true
and some many countries actually will
accept dollars because it is valuable
but for the most part dollars are good
in america with american citizens to buy
goods from americans and services from
americans
so that money being given away basically
just means you will do work
for other countries while your business
where your livelihood was completely
destroyed by these politicians
we are being extracted they are ripping
away the wealth
and i don't mean a lot of people on the
left this is frustrating i think wealth
means wealthy
rich wealth means like your accumulated
resources
your wealth could be a 100 bill in your
pocket i just mean like your resources
your money
your access your hard assets your
currency your liquid assets
they're stripping that away from you
devaluing it
and giving it away to foreign
governments
yeah it's really obnoxious yeah yes
it is insidious it is dastardly
i love that babylon bee article masked
bandits steal a few trillion
from your grandchildren yeah it's like
nancy pelosi wearing a mask
it's in plain sight i mean i think it's
in plain sight it's in plain sight to me
because we've been talking about it a
lot is it not in plain sight
in plain sight and everybody watches it
happen i mean look that's what i'm
saying it's gonna get real interesting
with the the democrats quitting and
the democratic socialists moving in left
and right populists disagreeing a lot
many of them absolutely hate and despise
each other but they all
really hate the establishment and they
all are basically screaming
that's a lot of missiles you're you're
firing off for somebody with two
thousand dollars
and it sure is everybody can see it the
establishment has lost control of this
so there's some optimism in that whereas
perhaps this leads to the the corrupt
establishment falling apart
and then a new wave of people who
actually care about the people come in
but then there's concern that it leads
to just chaos
you know things are going to get really
really bad like we were talking with ben
stewart about how 2028 is supposed to be
the end
of the winter period where we were in
absolute chaos and conflict oh i could
see that
the the end of the last conflict was the
end of world war ii so quite literally
up until the point where people are
killing each other and bombs are
dropping and all this crazy stuff is
going on dresden's happening
then finally when we declare we win that
was the start of the of the spring
so we're supposed to be getting into the
worst of it in the next seven years
maybe maybe we do i keep thinking about
china like the reason we we went in
well i guess it was it was when hawaii
got bombed when pearl harbor got bombed
but
really when hitler invaded poland is
when the world was like oh
whoops and went and declared war on
germany like britain france they all
declared war in germany after they
invaded
so if china wants to i know they're they
didn't
britain do nothing until they got
blitzkrieg or something um no
no first france and england they did
nothing neville chamberlain signed a
piece he's in our time yeah
hillary's cool time man of the year and
then hitler they gave him the su dayton
land which was part of
poland that used to be germany before
the treaty versailles world war one
actually took part of germany and gave
it to poland apparently the polish
government was executing germans they
were like this is polish land now it was
really horrible so hitler was like
that's reason for me to invade that was
his
and they gave him the su dayton land
neville chamberlain now it's good he's
not going to do anything crazy
then they invaded poland and that was
when britain and france declared war on
germany and then jeremy was like hahaha
and they
drove all these tanks into france
through the ardennes forest
and then france was like we give up yeah
france had this maginot line this giant
defensive line prepared this
impenetrable line but they didn't put it
through the forest of the ardennes they
were like they can't get through there
but germany had the tanks it was new
technology the unexpected technology
the blitzkrieg and china you know that's
the thing about going to war
is the unexpected technology exactly
yeah if we if we truly like
like it's it's a good point you're
saying with unexpected consequences if
right now we
all got you know righteously indignant
and said we must stop the concentration
camps in china
and then all of a sudden xi jinping is
flying around in a gundam wing like full
mech suit with like a giant sword and
we're like
oh man what have we done we can't stop
that we don't we don't know what kind of
weapons they're using cyber attacks
they you know many people believe and
i'm not going to pretend to know i'll
know all this stuff but
there's something called industrial
control systems and i talk to a lot of
people
who believe all the governments
basically are in a mexican standoff
where they've
infected the industrial control systems
of other countries and could flick a
switch and just take out all their water
pumps and their oil refineries and
electrical grid instantly
what's that that weapon it's
um it's like an air something in space
or an electromagnetic pulse
yeah where it can shut down all the
electrical grid
that's my biggest that's what my dad was
because we don't kill each other i
i don't know um i don't know but when
bannon was in the white house i believe
he was saying that
china had them yeah and i just remember
reading the article and being like
that's freaking terrifying
like that actually scares me so build a
double faraday cage
yeah you know in your basement store all
your your goods so you build the faraday
cage
and then you put a microwave in it and
then you put your stuff in the microwave
because microwaves are also a fair
decage
and then microwaves yeah yeah sounds
obvious so
you know a lot of preppers will buy
microwaves and then put cell phones in
them and stuff
but it's not enough you need more than
that because i've actually
been in faraday cages and they're not
perfect they can't stop
everything there's leaks right so you
build two layers
and then try and fortify it in the event
they have an emp weapon you might be
able to build i think
i think emps will will knock out
batteries too like discharge all the
batteries
really i think i think i've heard that
too something like that but you might be
able to build solid-state batteries that
could
like resist uh they just had the first
like breakthrough with a solid state
battery
it's like literally just happened a few
like a year ago or something they've got
these nuclear batteries where they store
nuclear waste
in glass carbon glass and it just
produces massive amounts of like
i don't know what kind of heat energy so
those those would
would defy i would imagine uh but then
you got to capture the energy
obviously i don't know what they got but
i'll tell you this if we you know we
recently had that guy come out the navy
patent guy saying we have reality
warping technology and warp drive
whatever he called it
and i think whatever the military's got
we wouldn't know
like the manhattan project was was crazy
compartmentalization nobody even knew
what they were building that's the crazy
thing
because they separated in different
groups smart so people were like i don't
know what i'm building i'm building
rivets
and then the only people at the top knew
what they were combining to make
one of the most powerful weapons mankind
has ever seen i would imagine that's
going on right now
you want to know what's crazy yeah the
bombs we dropped on japan
hiroshima nagasaki the bombs we have
today
are i believe 1 250 times more powerful
than the bombs we actually used so when
you see
you know the footage of these tests or
whatever you have no
idea what one icbm can do
because we've never actually seen it
used on a civilian population
we we've seen uh the first i think the
atomic bomb that we used was a gravity
bomb we just dropped it from a plane
now we have intercontinental ballistic
missiles the multiple independently
targeting re-entry vehicle the mirv
it goes up into the stratosphere and
then drops eight to twelve warheads and
then peppers just
all these bombs substantially more
powerful yeah talk about the nuclear
submarines that we don't
know are all around our coast right now
like the chinese nuclear submarines that
are just up and down the west coast that
we
can't detect they don't matter so we we
we might get some
you know righteous indignation and we're
like we must end what's going on in
china
and like i said i know it's silly to say
xi jinping in a giant gundam wing mobile
suit or whatever
but they might come out with you know
sonic weapons emp weapons
uh you know we heard about that story
about the havana syndrome where they're
using some kind of directed energy
weapon
to like make people this is this is
scary stuff so i don't know if this is
confirmed now wasn't it like didn't they
confirm some kind of weapon they
they didn't confirm some kind of weapon
i think they thought it was like some
kind of low level
ultrasonic frequency they didn't say
that it was a weapon i don't think
people were hearing a hum
and then all of a sudden they became
photos photosensitive
they were sick they would get dizzy
their memory would wouldn't be scary
that would sound too
yeah yeah when i was a audio engineer i
remember we had a huge long conversation
with another producer about how
certain frequencies can make you lose
control of your bowels yeah
the brown nose yeah yeah i'll sing on
the toilet sometimes
to try and hit that brown dog the
legendary triangle
no but it's true like um you can like
make people like just double over and
like yeah
[ __ ] them this is crazy so when i was
working advice one of the stories we
were working on was this guy who
specializes in photo
and directed energy weapons and we never
ended up doing the story because access
is always it was a challenge but
what people think about directed energy
weapons is they assume it's like you're
holding a a plasma blaster or like a
blaster from star wars
like lasers come out of it one of the
directed energy weapons he had
was it was a strobe light that flickered
different colors
that made you vomit wow it reminds me of
the trans metropolitan comics where he
has the bowel disruptor gun
powerful have you guys seen uh have you
guys read that that's the best comic
ever you gotta read it have you guys
seen the movie kick ass too
she has the sick stick where when she
pokes the girls with it they start
vomiting and trapping their pants
well so there's actually so they claim
we test them out
but it's like it's shaped like a gun but
it's a round strobe light a bunch of
leds in different colors
that when you point at someone in flash
it makes them physically nauseous and if
they if you hold it for
for i think like 10 seconds they'll
start throwing up so it they were they
were pitched as crowd control weapons
i don't know if they use them or i don't
know if it's legit there's also
the dazzler which is a directed energy
weapon it's a high-powered laser
and what you do is you hold it at
someone's face and you click it and
it blinds them for 30 seconds so the
easiest way to it's a
high-powered laser and the way was
described to me is like you know when
you like look at a bright light
and then you see there's like a spot
there for a second imagine if your
entire field of vision
was that and all you could see was that
weird spot but it was everything you're
blind
and then you have to wait for your eyes
to like you know come back
and like start seeing again that's what
dazzlers do you
they hold it and click it in your face
and then you're blind and they use them
in the middle east
directed energy weapons are serious
business man yeah
so we don't know so uh news came out
about four weeks ago about the havana
weapon syndrome whatever it was and
apparently they couldn't decide if it
was a weapon or not they
they kind of drag their feet on figuring
it out and i guess the cia
shut down the u.s shutdown ca operations
in the area and have been running the
embassy with a skeleton crew ever since
so canada pulled out all together they
pulled their diplomats out
and it looks like they have no idea what
happened and they're not interested in
finding out which is really interesting
to me it sounds like a weapon to me
i bet there's a whole bunch of crazy
weapons do you think they have rods
forgot
rods i don't know if it's i don't know
tungsten you said it was like
gravity tungsten rods that come down and
cause mass explosion when they hit the
ground
rod's from god probably yeah just
doesn't make sense anymore
i'm telling you well so especially with
china but it's it's psychological
warfare now
oh yeah and i i do believe that i
i look i think china is absolutely
fanning the flames of the culture war
because we are we are on the verge of
ripping each other's throats off in this
country
we had an article from the uh from the
epic times saying secession
like it's time to talk about you know
legitimate separation of the states
you've got i mean luke and michael mouse
on the show have been like maybe we need
a peaceful divorce before things get
crazy
and i i don't even think i know a lot of
people on the left whenever they hear
this
they immediately say like you're fanning
the flames i'm like it was john podesta
who told the boss i think he spoke with
the boston globe or or it was
related to the boston globe he had
advised west coast states to secede
or i'm sorry he had said it is better
that west coast to
states secede if donald trump wins like
that's what should happen
wow so it's been democrats talking about
this stuff
so it's not just republicans it is like
you know
you you know what i mentioned i
mentioned a couple like last week
that a lot of people like uh bill maher
mendes he did it wrong
he was like we can't have a civil war i
think it was bill maher it's like the
mason dixon
line would go through nana's kitchen it
can't happen
and it's like what makes you think it
would be a replica of what happened a
hundred and
you know 70 or 60 years ago it would not
be
very very different yeah and the borders
wouldn't there wouldn't be borders
canada and mexico would be thrust into
it it would be terrible but here here's
the main point
back then there was a moral fight
abolitionists
were storming like sign me up
i'm i'm in hans christian hag was not
even american and he was an abolitionist
i think he wasn't american he may have
become american but he was an
abolitionist who fought for the union
because slavery was wrong and must be
ended it was the north saying we will
and
slavery and the south saying get out of
here we can do what we want
like you know we have our rights our
states will operate as we want you have
no right to come in
and the north being like for one you're
not going to destroy the union you have
no right to do it and
you have people fighting a moral battle
over slavery there's no moral battle
today
the if if right now we're hearing from
democrats
yeah well if republican states leave
then they're going to suffer because
they're blue states subsidize the red
states and then i see all the
republicans going okay
yeah okay we don't want your money then
so if
right now i think if you actually had a
legitimate
like question between the factions like
an antifa
leftist or an establishment democrat how
would you feel if a red state decided to
leave the union
they'd probably mostly be like
good good riddance i guess
and if you ask republicans they'd
probably be like yeah absolutely bye
there's no moral battle like you're not
gonna see establishment democrats being
like we must preserve the union
you're not going to see it i mean you
might see corporate establishment war
monger types being like
we must preserve the military industrial
foreign
we're going to siege your ports and
maintain your oil fields we're not
letting the state
go in the corporate kleptocracy yes the
kleptocracy
will steal the seat of governor and
replace someone new there
i think you know there uh there was a
poll where they asked about texas
secession
when because you have you know alan west
endorsed this bill it's going
legislation that will actually allow
them to
vote on secession most people's like 65
said no they can't secede but it was
like 25 or so percent or more
said they should there's a small
fraction saying i don't know
but i think as things carry on like if
we get to the point
2024 donald trump wins right all of a
sudden
you're going to have all of the blue
states being like yeah that's a session
stuff like we're we're back on board
with that and then
the republican states are going to say
deal have a nice day i could see if
china started a splinter like that
if like different areas of china started
to go independent that would be like
maybe
the the end of the communist party and
and there would be a lot of
a lot more willingness to maybe maybe
become
military militarily active against china
and if that happens so i would imagine
if it happened in the u.s the same thing
people would think about that about the
u.s they go oh now's our chance
let's go let's take it so no secession
no breakdown right now
if we break up china just laughs yep
they say okay
it's more important that's why we stay
together is the bigger picture
but i'm i think that's what i was saying
like i think china fans the flames on
purpose hoping it's going to happen
because it's their victory yeah there's
a lot of bad things for them for sure
i would love to get a soviet expert in
here to talk about the fall of the
soviet union because it kind of just
happened peacefully
and i tried to watch a documentary and
it was very confusing i think a lot of
it happened behind the scenes and
corporations were involved
but it was peaceful it was the
dissolution of the soviet union like the
most
dangerous communist threat the world had
ever seen up to that point
maybe the most dangerous threat the
world had ever seen maybe besides the
romans
up to that point well or the us
depending on your asking
you know obviously so yeah i'd like to
see something like that go down in china
but i just don't know enough about
russia's uh i don't know man
but i'll say this should i should i
mention what you got me for
yes can you get me canceled again again
then should i not
no it's fine cassandra got me this
really great card game it's called
right or racist and it's
it's actually like it's it's i i was
wondering it's like it's gonna be like a
pro-trump thing or anti-trump thing it's
not it's
neither yeah there's actually like some
really really interesting
really interesting things so like the
cards ask you a question statistics
yeah there was one where it was like um
what was the one that was surprising oh
it was like
uh a study found that most female truck
drivers are lesbians yeah is that right
or racist
and it doesn't really mean racist it's
like are you a bigoted or and it turns
out it's like a stereotype
right is it a stereotype or is it true
and that one was true apparently that's
what the card said
and it's like and it shows a manga guy
and he's got like you know goatee and
sunglasses or whatever
and it's like it's true there are some
really
surprisingly messed up questions where
it's like this is true and it's like
yikes
i'm not even gonna i'm not even gonna
mention what they were but it's really
fun though
because like so i have to say i would
actually argue this
is moderately anti-woke because
some of these cards even if it's true
very much so would get you canceled like
i'll put it this way
if you who was it who got uh was it
tommy robinson
tommy robinson tweeted about statistics
in uh uh
uh child abuse oh yeah the uk rather and
they banned him for it
and like even imagine nawaz was like
whoa wait but that's true like
he got banned for tweeting a legitimate
article about crime stats
so i'm pretty sure those cards would get
you banned
yeah if we filmed ourselves playing this
it would just like we'd have to beep out
almost complete sentences yeah that'd be
so funny no
it's censored yeah and then we'll go to
the next card it's not true it's
actually
so you know right because like only when
it's true is it censored and then
like when it's not true it's like we're
fine yeah that'd be really really funny
but uh anyway ladies and gentlemen we're
gonna go super chats if you haven't
already
you have to do a couple things it's my
birthday yeah cassandra's birthday is in
two days yes so you have to do this for
both of us
smash that like button yes it is a
birthday like button smash
and uh uh you can get cassandra whatever
you want for her birthday but for my
birthday go to timcast.com and become a
member yes let's do it it's a
big birthday bash let's get everybody
say tim happy birthday we've become
members to your website we have good
news too we're like we're getting really
close to the new website it looks really
really awesome
and uh yeah a lot of stuff to come so uh
thank you all so much for
i mean we already have a whole bunch of
super chats for everybody you know
giving stuff is presumably for my
birthday because they all say happy
birthday you filthy animal you look good
for 40
and things like that but uh thank you
guys so much for the birthday wishes and
the like button smashings
everybody's smashing the like button now
see normally on the show i'm like smash
the like button like
100 people will do it now it's like a
thousand jumped instantly like
all right it's your birthday i'll give
you a like button now just because it's
your birthday
thank you guys happy birthday happy
birthday thank you
i am 35 years old so how weird
ancient yeah you know what's crazy is
like when like i'm 35 and i'm thinking
back to like
my 20s and my teens and i'm like
it really is interesting how when i was
like
i'm like man i've been skating for like
22 i've been skateboarding for like 22
years
geez 20 i've wow more than half of my
life has been
you know with a skateboard skateboarding
and doing all stuff and it's just like
really crazy to think about how much of
my life
there is it's weird yeah it's gonna be
crazy when i'm 60 and i'm like man i've
been skateboarding for like
70 years that's what you're gonna sound
like at 60.
i got i
yeah i probably sound the exact same to
be completely honest yeah
all right my friends we got everybody
just smash that like button that was
awesome you guys rock
but but for real it'd be really cool if
people sign up for timcast.com because
that's
like the big mission is to create our
standalone thing
and i'm talking with some comedians and
some writers about doing like
entertainment content that's not news
commentary and growing like a bigger
media brand that does more than just
talk radio type stuff so that's so fun
but we'll read some super chats
and uh a lot of happy birthdays
so all i can really say is like
everybody's saying happy birthday
ryan c says it is also my nephew's
birthday he is 5.
happy birthday march 9th is the i
believe it is the
the apex the peak of pisces
yeah when does pisces end do you know i
don't know nobody knows i don't know
yeah
no i'm a pisces in the sidereal zodiac
but an aries in the tropical zodiac
there's multiple zodiacs so it doesn't
matter is it like march 20th
i think it ends like i know nothing like
march 9th is like right in the middle i
know i'm a pipe do you identify with
your pisces yeah you guys are both do
you identify with pisces i guess i don't
know we got to get a swimming pool
it's true yeah we do have to go swimming
fishing 100 let's go
fish water signs so normally
rick ortiz says please slap ian as a
birthday present to all don't do it
a slap like a like a slappp yeah i don't
know
i'm just playing that one i i i do want
to read as many as possible but
a lot of them are basically just happy
birthday happy birthday birthday so
thank you all so much for happy
birthdays
fritter says happy birthday tim and
cassandra howdy to everyone else love
the show thanks
laughing dog bear says another night
with cassandra and then an emoji with a
bunch of hearts and roses around
and then a skull and crossbones oh happy
birthday tim my guess guest
jmac with the very big birthday super
chat saying happy birthday your big lug
thanks i've been a long time listener
for a while and i've been happy to see
how your career has gone
my wife and i are big time tim cast irl
fans and i've turned many of my friends
and
and family member onto your content
keep on keeping on it says contact but i
think you mean content keep on keeping
on absolutely and happy birthday to
cassandra thank you
carl says happy birthday to the milkiest
toastiest beanie wreck
i know thanks for all you do that's
right
xander klein says can't watch at night
but it's great to listen to you guys
while i work the day after
if the judges are afraid to pass a fair
sentence it just shows how bad things
are getting
stay safe all get that mobile app and i
want to hear this in the morning
we are going to be setting up a mobile
app as well super cool so most people
who watch the irl
special segment stuff uh it's on mobile
and so that's why it's like we've got
it's one step at a time we started the
website
tons of people signed up and i'm like
now we can hire someone to build like a
really big
powerful website and then the more
people sign up and each and every month
it's like more we can start growing and
expanding and
we're looking to do a lot more stuff a
lot more stuff
casey mcdonald thanks for the birthday
wishes it's a happy birthday
and uh crystal sparta happy birthday
lots of lots of happy birthday wishes
well here's bob who has uh he says the
wef the world economic forum had an
article called it's
30 you'll own nothing and be happy now
it's called this is how your city could
change by 2030.
yup would they rename the article and
they deleted
a video where it was like covid is
healing cities and they deleted it oh i
hope you got a copy
yeah yep yeah because they're like maybe
we shouldn't say the quiet part loud
that was a meme too like people kept
doing like the world is healing and it
was like
just ridiculous people dying coronavirus
[Laughter]
yeah
watch the movie kingsman you talk about
that a lot
because in the movie awesome movie
samuel l jackson plays a villain
who says that humans he says humans are
like a virus
and the planet is warming it's a fever
to kill off the virus
i just find it really interesting that
you have that and so the villain
basically decides he wants to
cull human beings and only the chosen
elites will be allowed to survive
to heal the planet that's his that's his
plan that sounds like good writing it
sounds like utopia or whatever that show
was
similar somewhere right i love that show
i like the the
british version yeah so now we have the
world economic forum saying
the world is healing well quite
literally a pandemic decimates
you know populations around the world
and destroys people's lives they're like
it's healing
it's like define healing you see how
they view it this is important
when they say the world is healing
they're not talking about people
and so it's a really scary thing when
people prioritize objects and
possessions
and other things outside of human beings
yeah so
look i'll be the first to say i asked
this of alex jones what if they're right
the world is on fire and about to end
and we must take dramatic action like
what if we are leading ourselves to
ultimate destruction
and he said it's a good question i think
about every day you know it's a
challenge
but i guess if you don't believe in the
authoritarianism of these liars and
kleptocrats people who
we we have caught lying and manipulating
us then we have to just defend
freedom liberty for the individual i
don't trust them i don't they're buying
beachfront property and flying on
private planes i don't think they're
being honest with us
we got rid of straws and now we're
killing all our sea turtles with masks
right it's all just ridiculous i like
the idea of spreading out we this is
something we talk about a little bit
before and tim if you guys don't know
was feeding peanuts to the crows and the
squirrels and they went to war for the
people yes they did
so after yesterday decided i'm gonna
make two piles of peanuts and now they
don't fight anymore
yeah so that was today so the other day
i put out a pile of peanuts
and because because i saw there was an
area where like we have a bunch of
human birds and there were some
squirrels and i was like i'll put out a
big pile of peanuts and then you know
let the animals kind of have at it and
then i noticed the squirrels and the
crows were
starting to go at it so first the crows
came down started eating and then they
would leave
then the squirrels came out and started
grabbing peanuts and running away but
then
when both the crows and the squirrels
were there they started doing the
shuffle back and forth where they're
like coming at each other and then like
if the squirrel get too close to the
pile the crow would jump at it but then
the crow couldn't pick up a peanut in
time because a squirrel would lunge at
it and i'm like oh no
oh no i've started a conflict and so
today
most of the peanuts were gone i just
left one pile there and i moved another
pile over and guess what happened
the crows just avoided the fight and
went to the pile of peanuts and started
doing their thing and there was like six
of them it was crazy
and then the squirrels were like running
over and the war was over so
the reason i bring it up is maybe we can
reorganize our planet or spread out into
other areas of the
the galaxy universe so on so there's
something like nationalism it's better
than this authoritarianism yeah maybe a
new nationalism
all right let's see marcus says happy
birthday to the new king of chicken city
yes we so we got these um they're like
little houses
they're like legit little houses for
chickens to like walk into and do their
you know chicken thing
and uh so it's like we have like i think
there's three
there's like two or three little chicken
houses and then like one
chicken community center and so you know
we're going to set it up and then we're
going to double layer protect it
from predators and then we're going to
have a little chicken set up some gopros
i think no i think it's a good idea to
talk my boyfriend
i do think it's a good idea for us to
get a computer and set up the live
chicken city campus you'll have one
chicken city cam like
big one and then you'll have one in the
house so they can see the house cam when
they sleep
and then they can swim
the weirdest stuff on youtube i like to
watch people harvesting carrots
i'm like oh is it going to be a big one
or is it
like i watch gardening channels all day
i love it and so like
anytime somebody puts out a carrot
harvesting video i'm like yes this is
the stuff
well what we can do is we'll we're not
going to get we can't get roosters so
this is a challenge because roosters are
important they protect and you know the
chickens but so we're going to beef up
security for the chicken city
and it's just the roots are too loud
like we do a show we can't have roosters
screaming all the time
but uh we could get a dog um luke has
you know uh atlas so maybe he could
train the kids no that'll be nearby i
don't think the cat
will probably probably want to kill the
chickens okay yeah
but um what we'll do is we'll name them
i think we can get four reasonably might
be tough because it might not be enough
excuse me enough space we'll name them
and then we'll do
real world chicken city and then we'll
do like we can film
fake little you know confessionals where
the chickens like you know
in a little chair at the camera and then
we'll do funny little things but then
once we have that
then people who watch chicken city drama
can narrate what's happening
to themselves like oh you know like
sharon just pecked at janice
like she's mad because janice is trying
to take take the
the protein layer and she and she knows
you know
and it'll be really funny
will actually protect the chickens from
chicken hawks interesting
really yeah i haven't confirmed it but
that sounded kind of tricky i'll google
that yeah
so what we can do is we can put stuff
for the crows around the chicken areas
and then oh yeah they like shiny yeah
you can also put string
going up above any fencing that you have
and
the hawks and stuff will see it and know
not to go in it because their wingspans
are too big and interesting
if they see things that are that are
impeding their flight
they won't go they won't go in so a lot
of farmers i watch homestead videos
literally all day
already yes but uh yeah they put string
across the top of the fencing
and uh seems to work so the chicken
houses are guarded
they're like protected and then we're
building a full
enclosure around chicken city so that
it's going to be covered on top as well
right but then we have the bigger area
where it's going to be exposed on top so
we'll do the string thing we'll leave
the strings on top
i'll send you the video i watched about
that it's pretty good it explains it
really well
we're gonna have to uh probably hire on
like a one-time chicken whisperer
who can like tell us like here's how you
set up the food and the water and here's
how you keep it clean and here's what
you should buy and here's what you set
up i can tell you how we did it and then
like you know heat lamps and stuff
yeah you know i like the idea of having
a chicken whisperer okay i understand
who can come in
when the chickens are like angry or
whatever and they you know pecking at us
they can like whisper the coos and the
chickens that like fall in line and then
start following orders did you ever see
that chi master that would go up to like
the bison
do this and they would all lay down one
by one i think they were bisexual
that's amazing it's on youtube one of
those stanley superhumans
nice all right big mac attack says how's
about i just give you my money and also
become a member what do you think of
that
baron von bini what if i also smash the
like button happy birthday tim
wow if you did all three absolutely
na lu says i love it when sour patch
goes yes yes
i tried not to do that paul sam says
every time i see cassandra on i donate
she rocks
in fact rock thanks guys happy birthday
cassandra
christian uh montague says happy
birthday tim you're my favorite youtuber
i haven't missed a podcast since you
started the show
much love to lids and ian cassandra's
cool too that's awesome man
here we go mike paula says world war ii
was 87 percent peaceful
on most days there were no battles true
it's it's true it really is yeah
fiery but mostly peaceful indeed yup
fair enough
delhiopola says my half asian son is
also a pisces like you so happy birthday
tim have a beer on me very cool thank
you very much
yeah we get these really great beers i
can't say what they are because it would
reveal too much information but they're
like
local produced they can it in front of
you they like pour it and then they put
it in the machine and they oh
okay later yeah oh yeah it's so cool
yeah so cool i want one yeah we'll get
some all right so
john sebastian matt says first super
chat ever guess your birthday is good
enough excuse keep up the good work and
happy birthday tim thank you all very
much
blackrock beacon says happy birthday tim
you've been amazing this past year and i
look forward to another amazing year of
great news coverage and new creative
projects
junior podcasts are a voice of reason in
unreasonable times never stop
doing what you do ps follow me on mines
thank you very much i appreciate it lord
trynan says
i was living in ferguson when the riots
were at their peak not far from where
the worst was happening
what the people of minneapolis are
feeling now i lived through too brace
yourself
friends yeah i was there on the ground
i was there with you yep we watched some
real crazy stuff go down
it was it was surreal driving down
fluorescent when west florescent when
all of the buildings were set on fire
and you're in people don't realize man
how much you like if you ever go to a
bonfire you probably will get it but a
lot of people don't get this
you're in the street you're hundreds of
feet away from this building that's
just engulfed in flames and it feels
like the fire is right at your face yeah
the heat output is exponential of a fire
i think it's hotter in the middle the
more
surface area so that that's a weird
phenomenon if you're not familiar with
it and people don't realize you get
sunburned
you know so i was with luke we were in
uh belfast during bonfire night or
whatever
and they have like how tall are these
things like dozens of feet tall or
like 50 to 100 feet or some ridiculous
number and this huge fire is raging it
burns into the ground
and you're standing far away and it's a
white
blinding light and you can feel the heat
and it's like
you point a camera at it and it just
like blows the camera out it's crazy
we are so vault we're in these
vulnerable bodies we've created such an
amazingly safe environment relative to
what these bodies can handle
we got uh i gotta tell you guys i
appreciate it but i think we have way
too many super chats to be completely
honest i don't know
you know i can't read through every
single one what a nice gift uh
uh povered says tim how much damage do
you think black lives matter is going to
do if he's found not guilty
if you thought last year's george ford
riots were bad that was when they're
like we demand he be charged
they charged him and they kept rioting
they kept writing after the dudes got
charged
so what do you think's gonna happen when
they're like he's free to go
they're going to it is going to be
i am so happy i'm up in a mountain now
yeah surrounded by right-wing nut jobs
like people talk about their plans for
it like there's specific trees that they
plan to cut down to shut off access to
our road and stuff
like planning ahead yeah i'll show you
some of it later but it's
pretty cool great i love it like my my
community is
they're very red
908 says can you make cassandra a
permanent member please
uh we can have cassandra on more often
let's just suppose if cassandra's we
might
be doing that podcast too uh i might
well we are done we are i wasn't sure
you know
how much we should talk oh yeah no yeah
so i already mentioned we're planning on
doing a crime cults mysteries and
paranormal podcast
so it's going to be i don't know it's
like it's like these subject matters
are kind of just like something about
like a darkness around the world like
you know i don't know how to describe i
already have really great guests lined
up
we need to come up with a name though if
anyone has suggestions please tweet them
at me
yeah it's hard because like everybody's
gotten every name ever mm-hmm
you know reminds me of like saturn at
live when they were like
i don't actually i can't tell the joke
because i think youtube wouldn't allow
it but
wow they basically made a joke about how
there's no domains left
and so it was a really awful domain for
a business and we'll start with that
because i'll get in trouble
some people might know the joke but
you'll probably get mad at me if i say
it
hefty fine says just a super chat
simping for cassandra
but also happy birthday everybody there
you go omg puppy says tim
george alexopolis put up a cartoon about
you an hour ago abducted by a ufo while
you were feeding your chickens
i saw it i reposted it so wonderful we
all retweeted that one
yeah g-prime85 on instagram and twitter
some of the best art we have george's
art on the walls because it really is
some of the best
like humor as well as just really good
yeah i don't know if i'm biased that tim
poole one is
one of my favorites just artistically
right the chicken who's like
jawed he's just hanging open staring at
the ufo
you gotta get it huge and put it back
there i want it behind him
like four times the size of these yes
that's great really big one maybe it can
yeah we can put it somewhere
yeah yeah on the back wall it will be
funny behind you at least actually yeah
yeah
it would provide some definition yes
yeah
we should totally do it george are you
listening we want the big
ufo chicken one i think he'll make it
happen it's game time
all right let's see we got not
heisenberg says congrats on your latest
trip around the sun thanks to you and
the team
thank you all so much
let's see rachel ianna says why does
lydia always have the last word
bye guys that's how long okay so that's
how long it takes me to judge
before i should click over because i'm
the one that pushes the button that ends
the show so let's try to give it a
couple seconds
that's why she's a powerhouse i must
have the last word
tristan mccartney says hey tim did you
hear about the accusations towards
stephen crowder and what is your opinion
i haven't what
what has there been accusations i know
he like tweeted out some video where he
went to the gym
dressed as a woman yeah and some some
leftist commented
stephen crowder likes dressing like a
woman a lot and i was like he does
doesn't he
yeah whatever but he does
i think shuan had made a joke about it
where she was like men
used used to look like this and then she
points to hassan and it's like him with
his shirt off taking a picture in the in
the mirror
and then she's like now they look like
this and it's crowded just like a woman
he's easily as big as his son
right i know but it's funny yeah that's
really freaking ripped but yeah that's
pretty funny i just think it's funny
that crowder is like a woman so often
i don't know how often he does it but
there's multiple occasions where he's
three times i think yeah he went to the
planned parenthood
to get a pregnancy test or whatever he
went to the women's march yeah
yeah it's good stuff but to be fair he
does in a lot of different costumes all
the time yeah
i think he just likes you know wearing
costumes his best being silly yeah
good content yeah funny oh judge
all right let's see um happy trip around
the sun tim from mr hellspawn cassandra
the penalty for
my thoughts about you are illegal in
several countries love you
great christina h says can somebody
please tell ian that he looks like ian
hills
judas priest offspring look up photos
from the 80s my dad and i love you all
it's cool to see cass back happy
birthday tim
yeah now yeah ian hills googling him
robert barnes hey robert how's it going
man says happy birthday great to see
your success and best to cassandra thank
you and thank you robert for the super
chat
he was uh robert barnes represented me
in the uk
oh that's right yeah yeah yep
cool stuff if it's the same right i'm
assuming yeah yeah
yeah okay i'm assuming it is too i don't
know it's the robert barnes
no isn't he doing something with viva
fray doesn't he yeah they do like a
podcast
yeah super cool sure hawkeye says tim
what do you think of the warhammer 40k
set coming to magic the gathering oh
that's right they're doing
is that they're doing it i like the
sound of it and they're doing lord of
the rings or something
cool yes yeah yeah that sounds sounds
fun i like warhammer do you ever play it
i have never played warhammer it's fun
it's like a tabletop dice rolling
kind of like d without the dnd
interesting yeah
here's an interesting point quinn reed
says the citizens united argument is
like borat too
should warrant two have been banned from
being released too close to the election
i don't think so i think sacha baron
cohen is duplicitous
but i certainly think he's allowed to
put out his movie and that's the worst
movie i've ever watched was it
you watched it yeah i was like i gotta
see what the fuss is and like i like
i like ridiculous comedy even if it's
like about our side
but like it was just gross it was i i
really
was not a fan of that one did you see
borat the first one
no i laughed a long time ago in the
theater but i couldn't stop it but it
wasn't political
it was just it was just trolling
ridiculously it was trolling people
it's crazy to me that in order to be
funny
you have to attack the other side like
so borah's whole thing is like mock
trump and his supporters but it wasn't
even funny
like there was that guy who did a parody
of like a cpac speech the other day
and he's a leftist and i thought it was
the funniest thing i have ever seen i
was cracking up and it
it's really like like it was so good
yeah you should like borat was not funny
it was gross
it was like period jokes and just like
gross
oh i hated it yeah
it was like awful it was just non-stop
like potty humor
yuck it was gross not my jam
all right let's see we got here fine
castle says hey tim long time lurker
turned member here i watched a video on
gamergate and the person and it
suggested that we need a follow-up to it
given the current climate in gaming
journalism thoughts
the culture war some say gamergate was
the first major battle in the culture
war we are
well beyond that you we don't even say
social justice warrior anymore
we say critical theorists it's like
really grown up in mature this is
almost was it seven seven years ago
seven eight years ago
so like these are people who are like in
their mid-20s
now in their 30s it's much more academic
and professional at this point
so i don't know if we need to follow to
gamergate some people have talked about
i've seen that
i think more so it's becoming more
academic but
i wonder if it's going to burst because
we did have a story we didn't talk about
maybe we'll talk about this in the
members only section
whoopi goldberg is is critical of the
cancellation of pepe le pew
oh and disney's like banning a bunch of
movies or whatever
so when you get people like whoopi and
she's like why are you getting rid of
this stuff
it's like i agree like just put a thing
on and be like it was an it's an old
movie whatever watch it or don't
good that's choice in one day i agree
with whoopee i don't know
what else did she say she had a great
video uh megan mccain was like
going on about stupid megan mccain stuff
whatever hell she says
and whoopi just looked at her like okay
yeah and i yeah i was like man that
that's relatable
she's sometimes relatable
she was uh she was great in star trek
yeah she was great
yeah that was fun i just watched the
ghost recently yeah
sister act was good i like whoopi
goldberg as an act as an actor
yeah i can't watch the view though i
remember i was reading about when she
joined star trek
and she apparently like reached out to
the producer or she told her agent like
get me on star trek and they were like
no no you don't want to be on this show
she's like yes i do and they're like no
really you you're so much bigger you're
a movie star
and she insisted so they got her the
recurring role i read i don't know if
it's true i just i
she brought like a nice sense of realism
to that show i think it was cool i think
dino was a cool character yeah
i think yeah i really like the i forgot
that the name of the episode is where
they
go through uh the uh um totally i'm
usually really good with my trek stuff
but it was when one of the enterprises
got pulled through time
into the future i love those episodes
which resulted in the klingons like
never signing a peace treaty with
uh um i can't believe i'm forgetting
the kingdom our courts jesus what the
heck never signing the kingdom records
and gainan was the one because she's
like an age-old being who
realized the time shift the timeline
shifted and then helped put it back to
normal that was a cool episode
star trek's so good i know too much
about star trek not enough though like
i'm not the biggest
but dude i really love that one so like
for those that aren't familiar basically
the klingons and the federation were at
war in this timeline where they never
signed the peace treaty to the kittimer
accords essentially
the federations on the verge of being
wiped out humanity is going to be
totally destroyed
but what had happened in the original
star trek timeline because the klingons
were bad guys in the original series
is that the enter the federation
answered a distress signal
because another alien race the romulans
i believe were wiping out a colony of
like women children and families
and a federation ship sacrificed itself
trying to save the klingons
which the klingons are very much about
honor and and like power and pride and
all that stuff and they were like it was
very honorable what you did and that led
to this peace treaty
it's great writing i just you know you
but you know why i talk about you know
why
i bring this up because it it makes me
sad to watch modern
creative content like modern tv shows
and stuff it's just
so dry so generic so boring so
repetitive
so blockbuster explosions and it's just
like give me a good
story inspire me tell me about how
humanity would have been wiped out were
it not for these
people who risked everything to save
their enemies
and that you know made the other the
kleon's be like
that was so brave and honorable like you
know thank you for helping us and then
peace comes i just love that writing
that's the stuff that kind of that
inspires me and then i see the stuff
today and it's like
white people who are immortal
sacrificing
an interracial gay couple it's a movie
called spiral and i'm just like
i get the message but it's just not
clever writing it's just
like very on the nose and not inspiring
in any capacity
it's just you know but maybe maybe i'm
just an old man you know and you're
in the subtlety it's normal maybe these
13 year olds these 15 year olds
who are on snapchat and tick tock or
whatever are like i thought that movie
was really great you're just a dumb old
man
and then maybe you know i'm gonna be
like abe simpson from that episode where
he's like
i used to be with it but then they
changed what it was now what it is is
different it scares me
it'll happen to you too
now what it is urban dictionary
but then they changed what it was so
awesome i started eating and yellowing
yeah well i mean people say yolo
especially the gm
the gamestop crowd and stuff which by
the way is up to 260 dollars oh
snap crypto did you become a millionaire
overnight
no but i i had i did hold my gamestop
stocks
yeah i can't say game stops stocks yeah
yeah i can't say it
so i just i just fully caved down and
did the yeah
speak but yeah it's way up i'm and i my
average buy is 133.
and it's 260 right now everybody's
yelling at me to sell and everything
oh check this out this is interesting
julie twomey says happy birthday tim and
cassandra as well my 35th
birthday is thursday the 11th curious i
was born at cook county hospital
grew up in cicero tim is it possible we
were born at the same hospital 35 years
ago
yes whoa oh yeah nice that's great
two days apart so i think it was cook
county hospital i do believe
that's where i was brought into this
reality
brought into existence you shared a
building yeah
there was this crazy thing i saw on
reddit where it was like apparently
there's a photo of some little kid when
he was like five
and behind him in the background there's
like a little girl playing
and then like two decades later they
ended up meeting and then it wasn't
until
they they end up getting married and it
wasn't until they were going through
like family albums that they were like
hey
you know i was there too and then they
looked and they have photos oh they were
cool
yeah that's crazy it's cool stuff
all right let's see where are we at
where are we at we got some more super
chats just a whole lot of happy birthday
so thank you all so much
philip ferris says you talk a lot about
world war ii but vietnam was the worst
slaughter of american children
oh yeah interesting american children oh
the soldiers jeez
of american children devastating if you
consider the 18 year olds kids they were
getting shipped
oh right right right yeah right yup yup
absolutely
casey mcdonald says is it too late for
me to uh to learn to skate at 24
absolutely not no i don't think so um
you can
just do whatever you want to do i've
never done it krigler got into
professional skating like in his
mid-20s yeah or not professional amateur
was he considered a professional he was
pro but uh it depends if in like the
core
culture pro and amateur don't mean
anything so like quite literally adam
uh was a pro skateboarder for i think he
was on our i think it was pro for arbor
i don't want to
yeah talk on it because i don't know
exactly he was pro
and like he did events and he made money
he was professionally skateboarding he
was telling me he never even
skated until he was in his 20s and all
his friends were skating he was like
okay
but so like in core skateboarding
culture
like you could be making a six-figure
salary as a skateboarder and they don't
consider you pro
until you get like a signature board oh
so it's kind of dumb
because it's always like you'd meet
people and it's like what do you do for
a living it's like i skateboard
professionally and you're like oh for
what company oh no no i own like a
school where we teach people how to
skate
and we film videos and then we sell them
to families it's like so professionally
i skateboard and produce content
but you're not jumping off buildings and
winning you know going to the olympics
or the x games or something you know
all right let's see we'll do a couple
more here a couple more
dentin uh andenson says tim happy
birthday to you and cassandra hope you
all had a good day
thanks for all you guys do ps your
shadow banning is increasing on youtube
i'm not entirely convinced that's true
irl for one is doing really really
really well just getting better and
better so
all right let's see just why says me and
ian have the same birthday april 2nd
lol happy b day tim and cassandra what
time i was 4 19 a.m
almost 4 20. almost almost almost april
1st almost 4 20. oh come on man
all right steph mlb says first super
chat happy birthday cass
your work's amazing happy birthday tim
it's true
guys age like wine looking good in my
country we have a saying
men age like wine girls age like milk
sad but true
and keep up the amazing work jeez it's a
brutal thing
it's very rare yeah
all right we're gonna talk about what
we're gonna jump over to the
exclusive members only section which
should be up in about an hour or so
and we're gonna be talking about disney
cancel culture because cassandra is like
a foremost expert on disney
i love disney yes like the expert a lot
everybody gets mad at me i realize that
they're social justice warriors and
they're terrible but like
i'm never gonna shake it just give up
it's still but but it's like cancel
culture stuff so they're apparently
they're like canceling a bunch of old
films or whatever we'll talk about that
so make sure you go to timcast.com
and you can grant me this wonderful
birthday present by becoming a member
and watching watching the content and
it's not it's not just a present you're
also getting these exclusive
episodes and segments it's gonna be a
lot of fun so we'll be there so
make sure you follow me on all social
media platforms at tim cast
my other youtube channels are
youtube.com timcast and
youtube.comcastnews we do this show live
monday through friday at 8pm so
you know come back like share subscribe
all the good stuff and if you're
listening on itunes spotify or any
podcast platform
leave us those good five stars or
however many stars you can give us a
good comment because it really really
does help
seriously that's how the podcast thing
works and uh it's greatly appreciated
cassandra you want to mention anything
yeah i'm over on twitter at sandra rules
my twitter account is very vexing i hear
so
be warned um i'm also on parlor gab
telegram everywhere else and i write for
gateway pundit
if you want to check it out oh you guys
can follow me ian crossland.net and all
my social networks thank you so much for
coming
thank tim happy birthday again it's been
a great year man looking forward to many
many more
bigger and better i like it and you guys
i love you so much thank you for coming
on the show
so my my favorite parts of the day is
hanging out on super chats and yeah
getting the feedback and listening and
interacting it's super nice
super quality yeah man and i'm sour
patch lids on twitter and at mines and
i'm real sourpatchers on instagram and
gab is that right i can't get my socials
right something's wrong with me
anyway happy birthday tim i'm very glad
i work for you we are going to be
i forgot to say it in mine happy
birthday thank you very very much oh
whatever you said it several times
already
yeah i've been saying we're gonna talk
about whoopi goldberg complaining about
cancel culture calling out respect and
disney cancelling stuff so head over to
timcast.com and we will see you all then
bye guys
you